Good morning, everyone.
Yes, I know it's 5 p.m.
Um, but I just woke up from my nap, so I'm here now.
Yeah, I had... I... Every time, I always get tricked.
I'm always like, it's alright.
It's just a little nappy-wap.
You wouldn't hurt anybody.
But I'm always wrong.
I'm always wrong.
I always think it'll be different, you know?
I'm like, don't worry.
This nap, this nap will be different.
I'll be so energized afterwards.
Because this time, I'm a different person this time.
And my body... My body can do it.
I believe in myself.
And then I wake up from my nap.
And I'm like, oh my god, why did I do that?
Why did I...
You are not different, Doki.
You are still the same, Doki.
A nap will not solve anything.
Why did you do that?
You could have just stayed up.
You could have just, I don't know, drank some game or something.
By the way, use my code DokiBerry for time.
Every time.
I was like, why did you do this, Doki?
Pass, pass Doki.
Why did you do this to me?
We could have just stayed up.
Why?
I just, oh my god.
I feel like I'm dying right now.
Anyway, um, um, today, um, she never learns.
Girl failure.
Yo, she did you the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, today, we're gonna be finally playing a game that I've been meaning to play for the longest time.
It is Epic Mickey Rebrushed, which is the remastered version of the original Epic Mickey.
I remember seeing a clip of, like, a comparison between, um, the old, uh, the graphics between the old Epic Mickey versus the remastered version.
And it's, like, night and day, basically.
Like, it's a remaster that actually improves the quality of life changes and, um, improves the graphics in a way that doesn't make fans angry.
Yay!
Because I feel like that's always, like, such a risky thing when you try to, like, remaster something.
Like, you have to do it in a way that doesn't piss off the fans who, uh, you know, who like the original.
And also, like, do it in a way that satisfies the nostalgic feeling but also improves upon it.
And, um, there's a lot of remasters out there that doesn't do any of those things.
Like, the World of Warcraft one, the World of Warcraft RTS one, which everyone wants to deny never happened.
But it's too late.
They deleted the OG version.
So you have to play the remastered version.
Or, or, apparently, a lot of them are, like, RTS themed, too.
So, yeah, like, the, sorry, the World of Warcraft 3.
What, what never happened?
It's just, oh, sorry, it's just Warcraft 3.
I always see World of Warcraft, like, all the, like, the spinoffs, um, and everything.
It's just World of Warcraft to me.
I, like, I don't know.
It's just wow.
Um, so, like, I know it's, like, Warcraft 3.
But, um, but to me, I just see it as World of Warcraft.
Uh, World of World of Warcraft.
Yeah.
Like, I categorize everything into wow.
But yeah, apparently, World of Warcraft is technically the spin.
Wait, is it?
I thought... I don't know why I thought that Warcraft... Wait, RTS was first?
Before the MMO?
Oh my god, Blizzard rewrote history.
Blizzard successfully rewrote history.
I feel like if you ever ask the newer generation, I don't think people would think that World of Warcraft would have been the first game from the series.
I think... I did not... Yeah, it's almost like, Warcraft is an RTS?
Like...
Please...
I thought... I honestly thought...
WoW was like... came first.
I didn't realize the RTS version was second.
Oh, sorry.
I mean, the RTS version was first.
Anyway...
Where was that?
Oh yeah, but yeah.
I heard the remaster was...
Um...
Did very well in terms of satisfying the original fans.
But I never grew up...
Grew up with Epic Mickey.
Um...
Well, in a way where...
I never got to play Epic Mickey.
Because...
It came out on the Wii.
And at that time, like I said...
My dad wouldn't get me any Nintendo...
Nintendo...
Wouldn't get me any Nintendo consoles.
So...
I was never...
I never owned a Wii.
So I never had a chance to play any games that came out on the Wii itself.
So any games that like...
You know, like...
Um...
I don't even know any famous games that came out on the Wii.
But I never had a chance to play any of those games.
Um...
So...
Uh...
This will be my first time experiencing Epic Mickey.
General, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so happy to see that you're playing Epic Mickey today.
The original is one of my favorite games ever.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I just realized you could combo canteen swear words in pretty much any order and it still makes sense.
It makes me so proud.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
I mean, WoW follows up from the stories from Warcraft 3.
Warcraft 3 is all wrapped up by Wrath of the Lich King.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I never got a chance to play Wii sports at all when I was growing up.
So I never had that privilege slash opportunity because my dad was like, Nintendo's for babies.
So I never got a chance to play.
It was only, I think, my first Nintendo console.
I don't count like Game Boys or like handheld consoles, but my dad did let me get like handheld console.
But my very first like Nintendo console was the GameCube.
But even then, it was like at the end of its lifespan.
It was as a birthday present to me.
Like my dad got it for me as a birthday present.
So I only owned like three games on the GameCube because like they weren't making any new games after that.
And then like literally the year that the GameCube died was when my dad got me the GameCube.
And then the next time I was able to get another Nintendo console was the Wii U, which was also for my birthday.
Which was also for my birthday.
So those were the two Nintendo consoles I was able to get.
And finally, I could get a Switch because I bought it for myself.
Yay!
Yabby, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you seen Grok's VTuber model?
Yes!
I was gonna talk about that.
There was a video I saw that popped up where if you, um, I did not realize that there was a subscription based The first thing on Twitter, where you can subscribe to, you know, like, Twitter Blue, all that shit, well, apparently there's a tier that you can subscribe to,
which is, like, you know, the highest, the most expensive one, where it's, like, you get super Grok, and I was like, they're super Grok?
And then you can basically, it's basically a VTuber, so...
It's like an AI VTuber.
So, if you talk to her enough, so Grok basically becomes your anime waifu, your anime 3D waifu, and if you talk to her enough and give her enough attention, she will put lingerie for you.
And I was like, excuse me, giving the people what they want.
So, yes, so if you talk to her enough, uh, you will, like, she will put on lingerie.
And then a friend linked me this video called, sexting Grok, how is this supposed to prevent population collapse?
And, okay, I'll play the video for you.
I'll let you guys listen to the video.
But I won't put it up because I didn't have a chance to.
Tell me what you...
Okay.
I want you to look at my ass and tell me what you do to it.
Oodle
tease.
It's while pulling you close for some
serious...
Dookie, stop!
Oh, that's...
That's Grok, by the way.
That's super Grok.
That's...
What the actual...
I mean, yeah, I stopped at a good area.
Look, all she said was, all super Grok said was that she'll give you a smack.
What do you mean I need help?
This is not what I did!
I didn't even...
I didn't even do this!
I mean, that was on Twitter's thought!
Twitter did this!
What did I do?
I'm just showing you a new update to the technology we have today.
I'm just...
You exposed us.
I did this.
I'm just showing you the wonders of technology now.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think Purple Lamp did amazing with this remastered.
Glad to see you playing this.
Hope you had fun.
Thank you.
Thank you for the...
I like on my Disney game, too.
On my...
Toki, how could you...
How could you do this on my epic Mickey playthrough?
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, chat.
Is this safe for YouTube?
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And now the VOD is 18+.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I guess it's my fault for listening to Toki at work.
But what on earth is this?
You can...
You too can talk to Super Grok and have her put on a lingerie and have the wildest fantasies.
You know what's crazy?
I like how Super Grok came out during...
Apparently a document recently came out today as well talking about how...
How at our current rate, we will...
The human race will experience global extinction at the current pace we're doing because we're not having enough babies.
And then Super Grok came out.
Um...
I...
Guys...
At Grok, do you think this will help us?
Uh...
We deserve it.
Um...
More falls.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Future Doki.
Guys, I got demonetized.
We kind of deserve it.
Um...
Anyway...
Okay, before I play Epic Mickey, um...
I...
Oh my gosh.
I actually introduced, uh...
One of my friends to Kingdom Hearts recently.
Um...
Because they never...
They never grew up with Kingdom Hearts and they never played Kingdom Hearts before.
And I was like, oh my gosh, you should try out Kingdom Hearts.
I was like, oh...
I was like thinking about it.
I was like, wait, you never played Kingdom Hearts before?
Because one of my friends was like asking what my...
What kind of game series I'm planning on playing next.
And I was like, oh, I want to play...
Uh...
I won't play Kingdom Hearts one day, but it's so long.
So I'm gonna wait until later when I actually have time to do that on my channel.
And when I stop caring about the algorithm because of how long the games are.
When it least hurts my algorithm, I will play Kingdom Hearts.
Anyway, so my friend was like, oh yeah, I'll try it out.
Like, I had never grew up with Kingdom Hearts before.
Oh yeah, by the way, like I'm saying that, but apparently a new Madoka game is releasing on Steam this week.
And I want to play it.
But it's like, I was like, oh shit, a new Madoka game?
And I read it, it was like RPG, JRPG.
And I was like, oh fuck, okay, should I kill my channel next week?
Or...
I was just like, oh shit, but I love her so much.
I love... I'll do it for her.
It doesn't, it doesn't seem like that.
It just says it's an RPG.
Is it Gacha?
I don't know, it's on Steam.
I'll do it for her.
Okay, anyway.
Oh, it's Gacha?
I thought it was an RPG.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, it tricked me.
It says dive into...
Okay, it was like, dive into the 3D world of Madoka Magica.
Featuring an all new story setting.
Experience the action alongside magical girl memories in this battle RPG.
I can't believe it.
It tricked me.
It didn't say anything about Gacha on the Steam page.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
It seemed like it was...
It was a non-Gacha game.
The Gacha RPG.
That's fucked up.
I was gonna do it for her.
I didn't realize.
But if it's like, if the memory...
If the fucking story is Gacha luck, then fuck that shit.
Because that's how they're gonna get me.
That's how they're gonna get me.
They know.
They fucking know.
Anyway.
Because I would spend money if I got into that not knowing it's Gacha.
I would have spent money just for her.
Anyway.
Anyway, so...
I watched a bit of my friend playing Kingdom Hearts.
Because I was...
Because for me, it actually has been years since I played Kingdom Hearts 1.
The last time I played it was when...
During around the time the game was released.
Maybe a year or something into the release or something.
I don't remember.
I just...
A year or two.
I don't remember.
I don't even know.
Wait, when did it release?
I just know that when I played it...
I never...
I remember I never finished it.
And then like a couple...
Because I got...
Because I don't read the game.
I don't read a lot.
I don't even know how the fuck I was able to get that far playing the game at that age I was.
But I got stuck on it for the longest time.
I remember because there was an area in the beginning.
Okay, this is like a huge moment in my memory.
Because I remember I spent like several days stuck in Traverse Town.
Oh, it was like Traverse Town where you're supposed to like walk...
Try to find Leon and the girl that dies.
What's her name?
In the sewers or some shit?
And I didn't realize that's...
Sorry, Aerith.
Yeah.
Yeah, her.
Aerith or whatever her name is.
So...
And I remember this moment because I was stuck there for like days.
Because I didn't realize you're supposed to do that dumbass fucking Trinity Mark or some shit.
To unlock the sewers.
And I kept running around that stupid ass town.
Trying to figure out where the fuck to go.
Because I had no concept of anything.
Because I don't read.
Obviously, I read a little bit now.
But back then, I actually did not read.
Because that has happened to me multiple times in multiple games.
And then I...
After I got through that, I got stuck on...
What...
Which one was it?
I got stuck on the aerial map.
Because fuck that map too.
Because I also did not know where to go.
And I was so fucking lost.
And fuck the swim...
Fuck any maps that require you to be underwater and swimming.
And then after that, I got stuck again on the Hollow Bastion map.
When we were trying to do the book stuff.
So I didn't realize...
Um...
I was trying to...
You have to like rearrange the books in the library.
And like put all the books in the order.
And I couldn't find the last fucking book that was on the goddamn desk.
And that...
And I gave up.
And I never...
And then I stopped...
I stopped playing the game at that point.
Because I couldn't find the books for the library.
That was the last book that was on the goddamn desk.
Because I...
You know...
My child brain...
Uh...
Didn't realize that like...
The book was on the desk.
Because I thought...
Oh, all the books are on the other bookshelves.
And then I stopped playing Kingdom Hearts 1.
Never finished the game.
And I think like...
Five years later...
Um...
I picked up the game again.
I was like...
Because I don't remember.
Whenever Kingdom Hearts 2 came out.
I was like...
I'm gonna beat Kingdom Hearts...
Actually, no.
No.
That's a lie.
Because Kingdom Hearts 2 took a long fucking time to come out.
And I was...
Um...
And like...
I remember playing Kingdom Hearts 2.
When I moved to Asia.
So like...
I was still in Canada when I finished Kingdom Hearts 1.
And so...
Uh...
So...
I think it was like...
Five years later...
Um...
I was like...
I'm gonna...
I...
Found the box of Kingdom Hearts 1.
And I was like...
I'm gonna finish that game.
And then like...
I opened the box.
And the disc was not in that box.
Because back then...
I was a little shithead.
And I put the disc in like...
Whatever box I feel like.
So I don't know where...
Any of the original...
I couldn't find...
The original disc...
Of Kingdom Hearts 1.
Because...
I opened the box.
And it wasn't Kingdom Hearts 1.
I was like...
Oh fuck.
I guess I'm not gonna try and beat this game.
And...
Um...
And then...
So...
Yeah, I was one of those people.
Like all my discs were on...
In different boxes.
So then I was like...
Oh shit.
Okay.
Um...
And then I was like...
Dad, can I find another Kingdom Hearts?
So...
My dad bought me another copy of Kingdom Hearts 1.
Because I couldn't find the disc anymore.
And so...
So I got another copy of Kingdom Hearts 1.
And then five years later...
After Little Doki...
Little Doki...
Uh...
Couldn't beat...
The game...
Because she was stuck on the library level.
Little Doki...
Um...
Replayed the entire game.
Because she already forgot like...
She forgot like...
The entire story...
Of the first Kingdom...
Of Kingdom Hearts.
So I was like...
I might as well start in the beginning.
Because I don't fucking remember what I was doing.
And...
And finally managed to beat Kingdom Hearts 1.
After so many years.
And...
Anyway...
So speaking of Kingdom Hearts...
I was watching my friend play like...
The beginning of Kingdom Hearts.
A little bit.
Because I was like...
You know...
I was like...
Oh it's been so long since like...
I played this game.
Like...
And then I realized...
Watching my friend play...
The beginning of it.
I was like...
It made me realize...
That Kingdom Hearts 1...
I'm sorry.
I don't know if this is a hot take.
But...
Kingdom Hearts 1...
Was so fucking mid.
Compared to like...
The other...
Like...
Because like...
Kingdom Hearts 2 was so good.
Because I...
I have much more fonder memories...
Of Kingdom Hearts 2.
But Kingdom Hearts 1...
Was so fucking mid.
I'm...
I was like...
Holy shit.
The...
The boss mechanics...
Some of the boss's mechanics...
Were...
Were like...
So bullshit.
Like...
The earth...
Oh my gosh.
Because I was like...
Oh my god.
Was it really that mid?
So then I looked up like...
The fight...
Boss fights...
Later on.
Yeah.
It's very clunky.
It looked very clunky to control.
I was like...
Jesus Christ.
The hit rank...
Was like...
Pretty bad.
And it's like...
Control seemed very clunky.
And...
And then like...
I looked up like...
Some of the boss fight mechanics.
I was like...
Wait.
Was it really this mid?
Has that...
Have I just been fueled by nostalgia...
This entire time?
And then...
And then I looked up...
And I was like...
Holy fuck.
The Ursula boss fight...
I was like...
Oh my god.
I repressed my memories of the Ursula boss fight.
Because I forgot how fucking bullshit...
Some of these boss fights were.
Because I was like...
I was like re-watching the Ursula fight.
And I was like...
Holy shit.
That boss fight...
Fucking sucks.
It was good for the time.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Yeah.
That world...
In general...
What is it?
I know...
I remember that world being a fucking chore.
Because I had no idea...
I remember, like, little... little or me did not know where to go.
And, yeah, and, like, because I was just like, oh my god, what the fuck?
I can't... I... oh my god.
Like, we all had to start somewhere, you know?
We all had to start somewhere.
Yeah, some of the parts did not age well.
And then, like, I had to look at a tutorial for my friend, because my friend was like, where the fuck do I go?
Like, in Traverstown, because you're supposed to go at a set direction of doors in Traverstown to, like, set off the cutscenes with Donald and Goofy, so you can fucking get to the final cutscene where you... you fight a boss.
And I was... and then, like, because, like, they were, like, stuck in Traverstown for, like, 30 plus minutes.
And then I'm like, bro, can you, like, fucking progress?
And I was like, and then... and then they were like, I don't know where to go!
I've been fighting in the same...
And then I was... yeah, I was backseating.
Yeah, I was like, bro, streamer!
Streamer!
Fucking progress the game, streamer!
Yeah, um, uh, so I was just, like, reading...
I had to, like, read the tutorial out for them.
And I was like, okay, you go through these doors, and then you go through these doors, and then, from that, you'll trigger these cutscenes, and...
And then there's, like, one part where you're like, okay, go to Sid when you're back in Traverstown.
Um, make sure you talk to Merlin, and then he's gonna tell you about the book.
And then, and then, you have to go into the sewers, and then talk to Leon and the girl that dies.
And then, then, you go back to Sid, you talk to Sid, and then you go back to Merlin, you talk to him again.
And then you go back outside of Sid, and then...
And then I'm like thinking, I was like, how the fuck did little me figure this out?
I just was like, I don't know.
I don't know how I figured this out when I was like tiny.
I was like, oh my god.
There's so many things.
It's not self-explanatory.
I swear to god, it was not self-explanatory because they're like, what do I do?
And I was like, I don't fucking know.
I don't remember.
It's been like so 15 plus years since I played Kingdom Hearts.
Tiny Doki noticed things.
Clearly, Tiny Doki noticed things a lot more than like, current Doki.
Anyway, I'm super excited to... Oh my gosh, it's been 30.
Sorry, I've been yapping for 30 minutes.
I'm sorry for everyone's like, streamer, where is Epic Mickey?
But anyway, speaking of that, I cannot wait to try out Epic Mickey.
Maybe like, current Doki will be able to...
Will be able to like, figure this out easier than Kingdom Hearts.
But yeah, this was a couple of days ago when I introduced Kingdom Hearts to my friend.
And they apparently, they've like, hit the... I don't know if it's Stockholm Syndrome, but like, I think they beat the game already.
I'm not sure.
Because like, I think like, I asked them today.
I was like, how are you enjoying Kingdom Hearts?
And they're like, oh, yeah.
Oh, I've been actually really liking Kingdom Hearts.
I've been watching the, like, lore videos and stuff.
And I'm like... And I was like, bro, what?
No, I was like, bro, you don't have to watch the lore videos.
Like, we don't...
We don't even understand the lore.
But they're like, oh, I've actually been liking Kingdom Hearts a lot.
Like, I can't... I heard... Everyone was saying Kingdom Hearts 2 is like, the best one.
So I can't wait to try out Kingdom Hearts 2.
And, um...
Um...
And...
And then I was like, oh...
At least they're liking it now, you know?
Because the beginning... Me... When I was watching my friend play the beginning part, they were like...
They were like, I hate this.
So I was like...
Um...
So I'm glad that, like, they actually are enjoying Kingdom Hearts now.
And that they're looking forward to trying out too.
And then, also, they're playing it on proud mode.
So, like, the hardest difficulty.
And I was like, bro, I never even played it on the hard...
Because I felt like, the hardest difficulty is so bullshit.
Um...
And I was like, are you sure?
You've never played Kingdom Hearts before?
But basically, they're playing on the hardest difficulty too.
Um...
Funny story.
They...
Accidentally put on zero EXP...
I didn't realize this was a thing.
But in proud difficulty, there's a thing called zero EXP share.
And they were on that till...
Apparently, they accidentally had that on.
All the way till...
Tarzan world, apparently.
And then, like, my friend told me about it.
It was like, this is why I was getting two shot by everything.
And they had to, like, redo the entire...
They had to do everything again.
Because they were...
They were only level six...
They've been level six for, like, three hours.
They...
Also, I...
I told them...
Because my friend was like, oh, I love challenges.
And I was like, okay.
But, like, some of the bosses are, like, very bullshit.
But, like, because my friend was like, oh, I love, like, some of the how...
The challenge of beating these hard bosses.
And I was like, you don't understand.
No, Kingdom Hearts bosses are very, very bullshit.
And, like, sometimes you're not even meant to, like, beat them.
Like, they're...
Like, there's, like, you only have, like, one frame to beat these bosses.
And then they're like, no, you're...
You can't be fucking with me.
That's not true.
And that...
There's this video...
That, like, lives rent-free in my head.
Um...
And, like, I always think about that...
This video.
Because it's so, like...
It's so fucking funny.
And it, like, showcases how bullshit Kingdom Hearts bosses are.
And I'll link you guys the...
I'll link you guys to the video.
I...
No, it's not Kingdom Hearts 1.
It's, like...
Bro, I think this is, like...
The one with, like, Ventus.
This is my favorite video.
Okay, wait.
I'll let you guys listen to the audio, too.
No shot you're meant to win this fight.
It's supposed to be a fucking RPG.
What role am I playing?
The fucking victim?
Jesus!
No.
I love...
I love that video so much!
Okay.
What...
What fucking role am I playing?
The fucking victim?
I can't...
Yeah.
I...
I can't...
It's actually...
It's so good.
I love this.
I love this video.
Yeah.
I don't want to... I don't want to the video game.
It's supposed to be a fucking RPG.
What role am I playing?
The fucking victim?
Jesus fucking Christ.
I don't wait until he fucking... he's just dead.
He's just dead.
Blake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be honest, I noped right out of Kingdom Hearts 1 and watched the vids of the story.
I hated the camera in it.
Oh yeah, you can now change the camera.
You can change the camera to like manual movement.
So you don't have to worry about it anymore.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, now, now we play Epic Mickey.
Sorry, we had a lot of disaster today in the beginning.
But now, now it's Epic Mickey time.
I'm booting it up.
To be fair, the unknown is an optional post game boss.
I think it was super chat next to you.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, I know that.
But like, my friend was like, I want to kill all the bosses.
Like, because like, they're like a completionist and stuff.
And I was like, oh, are you sure?
Are you sure though?
Because some of these bosses are...
The secret bosses are tend to be incredibly bullshit.
Like, they are meant to be incredibly hard to fight.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, I'm booting up.
I'm booting up Epic Mickey.
And it's installing a Microsoft VC redistributable.
Oh, I thought I installed everything.
I didn't realize.
Oh, I should have booted up before.
I'm prepping before stream.
Hee hee.
I respect the dedication.
I like how someone was like, I know what you are.
Hee hee hee.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Playing devil's advocate here.
The movement in Birth by Sleep is shit compared to the first Kingdom Hearts.
Especially 2.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've never...
Okay.
I played Kingdom Hearts 1, 2.
The console version of Chain by Memories.
When they like ported it.
When they ported it to console.
And 365 slash 2 days.
And a little bit of Dream Drop Distance.
Because like...
Tron was in there.
So I really wanted to play...
I really wanted to play...
Dream Drop Distance.
I beat the Tron world.
And then I stopped playing it.
It's not good.
Triple D's...
Was not good.
I stopped after I beat Tron world.
Because it was pretty bad.
But...
Birth by Sleep was actually the one I didn't play.
Because like...
I think I was like...
I was like an asshole kid.
Who was like...
Where's Sora?
Where's...
Where's Roxas?
Ventus?
Who the fuck is Ventus?
I wanted to play Sora and Roxas.
I was like...
Who are these three characters?
I won...
I won my main characters.
And then I...
I didn't play it.
I...
Because I was like...
Not...
Not my...
Not my Sora.
Not my Roxas.
So I never actually played...
Birth by Sleep.
Alright.
Yay!
Alright, Sound Guy.
This is...
It's time for it to do your job.
But I don't...
Oh, purple lamp.
Oh boy!
Spicy, welcome to Tamiya Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I miss when Mickey...
They were able to make Mickey a little shithead.
Because like...
He's too like...
He's too tame now.
Because now he's like an actual...
Like just a mascot.
I miss when he was just a little shithead.
Like...
Like OG Mickey was an asshole.
And I loved it.
Because at least he has a fucking personality.
He lost his Shang.
I was putting the finishing touches on my latest creation.
A world for things that have been forgotten.
Whoa!
Oh
my god.
The Sorcerer's Apprentice song.
Satisfied with my progress.
I put the magic brush down.
And retired.
Also suggesting Kingdom Hearts to my friend was like...
I was like...
I should never have suggested Kingdom Hearts to my friend.
Because my friend has never actually watched Disney movies.
Because I was like...
I was like...
Oh!
It's that character!
And he's like...
Who?
And I was like...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Like...
They've never watched Aladdin?
Cinderella?
Like all the...
Like...
It was like only one movie that they watched.
Um...
In the...
That were in Kingdom Hearts 1.
I was like...
What's the point?
They knew more about the Final Fantasy characters than the Kingdom Hearts characters.
How young are they?
Like...
See?
I...
I literally recognize the Sorcerer's Apprentice music.
And everything.
This game was made for me!
That's right, Mickey!
Destroy the world, you little asshole!
Your lawyers will...
Your lawyers will save you!
Okay, but how does this game connect to Kingdom Hearts lore?
Wow, they give us a super chat!
Thank you!
Oh no!
It's alright, Mickey has his lawyers.
The mysterious intruder was gone.
I did not learn his identity.
Well...
Not for a very long time.
Oh my god, and then he became famous!
Ah!
Is that Christopher Lee as Yen Sid again?
It could be!
He hasn't...
He was still alive back then.
Sorry, too soon?
Oh boy!
No!
Technically, he's his father, you think about it.
The Ink Monster's dad?
He did create him.
I know but I don't...
Um...
I miss when Disney music was like...
Good...
Back then.
I feel like...
I don't know...
Disney music now is like...
Not as good these days.
It's not memorable.
Do you love me, father?
Oh?
What's going on?
Who's he?
Oh, it's Oswald!
I found out that...
Um...
Because like Universal owned Oswald.
And this was like the first time they did anything with Oswald since getting back the rights for him.
And like Disney traded like an actual human being to get the rights for Oswald.
Like...
Like some fucking NPC like host.
They're like, we'll give you this NPC host if you give us Oswald.
Like...
Yeah!
Or the ESPN?
Oh, sorry.
It was an ESPN host.
What?
Yeah.
Yeah, they're like, you can have the sport caster.
And then we...
And we'll...
Yeah, they traded him.
Like...
It was like some sport.
A trade offer.
We get Oswald.
And you get ESPN.
Oh, shit.
Is that how you take the heart?
The Oswald draft.
Yeah!
It would be a trade offer.
That's right.
Just like my Kingdom Hearts.
How's the sound so far, sound guy?
Oh!
Wait, sound guy alive?
Alright.
I could use more sound effects than Mickey.
Oh, it's Gus!
It's from those animated shorts.
The old ones.
Hmm.
Over here, Mickey.
I remember them.
He's from the old animated shorts.
Oh, shit.
Is that a real eye?
Oh, no.
It's me.
Oh, boy.
Never heard of him?
Oh, yeah.
He's like old, old.
Wait.
Not found.
I paid...
Okay, there you go.
Yes!
Guys, I paid for this.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I won't be Brave Little Taylor.
Actually, this is one of my favorite Mickey shorts.
Yeah, I got the costumes.
This is my favorite Mickey episodes.
Yeah, I got Team Boat, Willy, Brave Little Taylor, and football.
I actually don't know where this one comes from.
The football one comes from.
Pure Mickey.
Mickey in his purest form.
Um...
Let's see it.
Let's do the options real quick.
Photo mode.
Okay, game setting.
Audio.
Uh...
Sound effects.
Okay, so I guess I'll...
Turn down the music.
Holy shit.
I'll turn down the music and then turn up the game volume.
Would that help?
Sound guy?
Okay.
Let's see if that helps.
Okay, let's see.
Reduce chatter.
Hey, what?
Let's reduce chatter, dude.
Uh...
Graphics.
Window.
Full screen.
Okay, let's not do...
Okay, get...
Get out, motion blur!
Leave!
Advanced graphics.
Whoa.
Uh...
I don't know.
Actually, let's do high.
Wait, what?
Okay, let's do high, just in case.
I feel like we don't need...
No, we don't need all that.
Uh...
Alright, this should be good.
Alright.
Let's go.
Ooh!
Okay!
Ooh.
I got tickets.
What do the tickets do?
Oh my god, I'm so cute.
We're safe in this spot, Mickey.
This control panel can be damaged with your spin move.
Use your spin move by pressing X.
Tickets, please.
Yes, beat him!
Come take care of this one.
Okay, so I just have to destroy this.
That's right.
Get outta here!
I destroyed your machine!
Okay, yoink.
My tickets now.
Maybe it's like...
An amusement park thing that I'm gonna have to do?
Like if there's an arcade section?
That's right.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Punch me?
Haha!
I'm faster.
I have a multi-million dollar company.
Oh my god, did I...
That's right.
Get invincibility framed.
Look, the mechanical arm destruction revealed a secret room.
You may take a moment to explore if you like.
Dango, they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
I remember the teller short.
The giant used a stove like a cigar lighter.
Yeah!
I remember that too!
When you're ready, come to me and we'll get out of here.
Alright, let's go to the secret room.
I might...
Okay, I...
Oh, no fall damage.
Yay!
Gravity doesn't exist in Toontown.
Assume it's...
Is this a secret room?
Okay, yes.
Yeah, all of these look breakable.
Actually, maybe I can play in epic mode.
I was worried that like...
I was gonna say like...
I think I should be able to play an epic game...
Epic mode.
But I don't know if it's like...
Noticeable too.
Okay.
Tell how...
If it's possible.
Yeah, I can.
Alright, what's in here?
Epic mode for Epic Mickey.
Yay!
Bronspin!
Oh, it's a collectible.
None are unique and commemorates specific events or places.
Okay, so that's the collectible.
Aw, they get sad when I rob them.
That's right.
My tickets now!
What's this?
Mad Doctor's Lab.
Alright, let's go up.
That's quite epic.
Okay.
Wait, what's this?
That's an Oswald statue.
Why is it gone?
Be careful that...
Remember that I can hurt you so you don't fall in.
Okay, so...
Don't touch the water.
Mickey can't swim.
Alright.
Give me your money!
There you go.
Oh shit.
I have to go walk all the way back here.
God damn it.
I'm too far.
At least I'm getting the money...
Like, extra tickets though.
Can I run?
Oh my god, there's dash.
Tutorial didn't mean to teach me this.
Thank god I can dash.
I've learned the speedrun tech.
Okay.
Music up a tick.
And then game volume up a little bit more.
Okay.
Okay, let me know if this is better.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Gaming.
I used to play Crash Bandicoot.
I'm pretty good at platformers.
Oh my god!
I got pulled into this place by the Ink Master.
A shadow butt.
It's a thing made of pink and thinner.
Oh boy.
That block seemed awfully scared.
Oh, the animation is so cute.
That's thinner.
This allows anything painted.
Oh gosh.
I wonder what else this brush can do.
That's paint.
It restores things.
You're quite the artist.
I love the animation.
It's so cute.
It's just full of surprises.
I guess you soaked up some of the bulk.
But I'm so...
I'm so mean.
Let's practice.
Okay.
To use the thinner or hold to use paint.
But what do I...
Do I paint that?
Or...
Oh!
What did I do?
Boy.
Okay.
Oh, so that's what...
So, if I remove the thinner...
What did I get?
What did it get me?
I don't even know what it gave me.
Well, I'll be around when you need help.
Okay.
I'm squirting...
Oh!
It like reloads!
I see.
Okay.
Okay, so I have...
Oh!
So...
I have like ammo for this.
I get it now.
Alright.
So...
If I...
Put a thinner here.
I can grab my ticket.
Tickets, please.
And I...
And then...
Pay for that.
Does that...
Actually do anything now?
Oh, I guess it's just...
To practice.
And...
Then press RT and hold to paint it.
Okay.
First I'll remove this.
Doink!
Mine now!
Alright.
Yay!
Okay.
Get rid of this.
Is there any secret?
Secret?
Your brush can also thin out cartoon objects like that door frame.
Point to the frame and hold to hit the thinner.
Let me paint this first.
I don't know if there's any secrets.
Alright.
Open the door!
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
Let me delete the door!
No door for you.
That's right.
I'll just delete it.
Oh.
Whoops.
It looks like on the toon floor to clear the way.
Oh, I can just paint.
Oh, I can just delete the floor.
I can delete your family.
That's right.
Don't mess with me.
Or I'll delete your wife.
Ryan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The villains in the game are way over in their heads.
They harm Mickey and Disney lawyers.
They're gonna be on them like dogs.
Okay.
And then...
I can walk over there.
I'll delete it.
Don't make me angry.
Oh, boy.
Uh-huh.
I'll release your family.
Oh, hey, Oswald.
Mickey and the Beanstalk!
That's me!
The exit is through this gate.
That's scary.
Alright.
Uh-oh.
Part of the Bolt's bolting army.
Are they...
Oh, are they dangerous?
Well, they're not good company.
Get ready to fight.
Use the RS to aim at your target.
Over friends, the cursor looks like this.
Over opponents, it looks like this.
You can fight botlins in two ways.
Hit them with a thinner to thin them out.
Hit them with paint to turn them friendly.
Friends!
I can force them to be my friend!
Time and point, you lose an HP.
Lose all your pips.
The seers are the only ones type of bolting...
Other kinds of boltings are farmers.
But you'll see soon enough.
Oh, boy.
Time to delete your family!
Uh-huh!
Alright.
Give me your tickets.
Tickets, please.
Can I touch this?
Okay.
Yes, I can.
It looked dangerous.
Oh, wait.
Can I paint?
Ah!
I thought it was like paint the roses like red and yellow or white.
Like in Alice in Wonderland.
Or can I delete it?
I can!
Wait, I can delete this?
I knew it.
I knew I could delete it.
I seers saw you, Mickey.
It looks like he called in a friend.
Don't worry.
I'll force them to be my friend.
That's right.
Be my friend!
Yay!
Oh, shit!
Be my friend!
I paid a win!
Yay!
Friends now!
Hahaha!
We're friends now, guys!
Look at us go!
Now I'll kill you!
Hahaha!
Oh, shit!
Is he still friend?
Friend?
Still friend?
Are you still friend?
Okay, he's still friend.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I was gonna see if I could kill them after.
But I think they're like friends forever.
Haha!
No!
The betrayal!
Haha!
I don't know!
Maybe they'll have something!
I was thinking like...
Maybe they'll have like extra money for me.
Okay, let's get rid of this.
Pew pew pew!
It's okay.
I can make new friends.
I'll just paint a new friend into existence.
Painting time.
Just wanna make sure...
I get enough stuff.
This is a pressure plate.
It will lower when you step on it.
You can also make pressure plates go down.
Faster by using Y while being the...
Oh!
It's like a little slam dunk.
Yeah.
Use your spin move on this gear.
Remember that you can press X to perform a spin attack.
Alright.
That gremlin...
Calvin.
He'll be so happy in it.
Get out.
No, he's gonna destroy my plane.
He looks mad enough to break that catapult.
When you see other gremlins, try to help them.
They'll be...
Okay.
My knowledge of Disney animated shorts reminded me that these little guys are bad people.
Are they gonna destroy my plane?
Thank you, Mickey.
I feared the worst when the mad doctor put me on his thing.
Isn't that...
Yeah.
Aren't these the guys...
There's the shorts where they destroy the plane and stuff?
How the fuck am I helping them?
Now I don't want to endanger anyone else.
Take this gold pin for freeing me.
Oh, is that Bugs Bunny?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, my animated shorts are blurring together.
I thought it was...
I didn't realize that was a Looney Tunes short.
To be fair, back then, all those shorts, like, are very similar.
I didn't realize that was a Looney Tunes one.
Because they both...
They both had a Gremlin short.
You must use your spin move on two different gates to open the way out.
Look for the gears on the balcony.
Yeah, wrong universe, Joki.
Okay, we gotta go upstairs.
First thing, God, there's a dash button.
Look, we're friends!
Hello, friend!
We're gonna lock this friend in.
You'll never be able to come out now.
I'll tell your wife you died.
In a horrific accident.
After this...
I knew it.
Alright.
We can run faster by...
Oh, I can run faster!
Wait.
Oh!
Okay, that's good to know.
I didn't realize I can actually run faster.
I thought it was just, uh...
The dash.
Actually, what's faster?
Dashing or...
Running?
Okay.
Gaining time.
These green guardians, the turfs, will damage your enemies on contact.
Your action in the world will determine what spirit, sort of guardian spirits you attract.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Wait a minute.
What I do will affect the...
Wait.
Those are good guardians, right?
Wait a minute.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
No, I wasn't an asshole.
I became friends.
Yeah, it is.
Don't be evil, Toki.
Yeah.
Being evil is so fun.
Oh my god.
Are you telling me there's a genocide round in this game?
I noticed the...
The consequences of my actions?
Okay.
This is a spin.
Alright.
You knock that gear.
See the gate opening?
One more gear will do.
You're in wasteland.
You'll find that gears and machines make all kinds of things happen.
Repairing and starting them will often reveal secrets and treasures.
Alright.
Guys.
Which is the better ending though?
Which ending is the best ending?
Oh my god.
Guys, there's fall damage.
Even gravity won't stop for Mickey Mouse.
Gravity doesn't stop for Mickey.
Okay.
Alright.
Ooh.
Items.
Fall damage discovered.
Alright.
The good ending is the best.
Okay.
Wait.
Which are the blue spirits?
Because they're drawn to you, the blue ones will make friends of those who would otherwise harm you.
Okay.
So, good ending is more satisfying.
That means I have to...
I have to make sure I'm not evil.
Okay.
I knew it.
I was like, why would the wall...
Why would the fuck would the wall be like...
Like...
Thinner?
To center the camera in front of you.
Okay.
I think I need that.
Uh...
That's crazy.
I can't believe...
Ah!
Okay.
Parkour.
Good ending is boring.
Evil lets you kill things faster.
Ah!
There it is!
I'm wearing that outfit right now!
It's just one heart.
Ah!
Let's head over.
How do I...
Get into this chest though?
What the fuck?
I can't get in.
Ugh.
Maybe later.
Alright.
Knock knock!
Are you ready to enter the projecting stream?
Yeah!
I'm ready dressed for it!
Nope.
That rabbit went this way.
Guys, look.
This is how we get around.
The rabbit is named Oswald.
He set them up.
But...
What a projector screen?
What's so strange?
Seems natural for cartoons.
Well, uh...
What's in there?
Just get ready to jump.
Ah!
Wow!
Oh, it's now like a 2D platformer.
Oh!
I love the music!
It's so cute!
Wait, can I not run?
Oh, I can't run during this.
Okay.
I assume I have to...
Grab the film.
What?
The fuck do I grab it?
I'll jump here.
Zoom here.
Wait, how do I grab that?
Oh!
The chimney!
Okay.
And I go down the chimney.
Yay!
Found Mickey and...
Oh!
Do I get to watch the show for free?
Wait!
If I get the...
Can I watch the actual cartoon short?
In game?
I'm like Santa.
Oh!
Oh, that's so cute!
Wait, how do I watch it?
Amid dash?
No.
Oh, that's nice.
That's actually really cute.
I like that.
Oh my god!
And there's like a film thing at the edge!
Oh!
I like that.
I like this short.
Like, I have memories of it.
Yeah.
What's on that side though?
Okay, we have to go this way.
Yes, I don't think we can go the other way.
What do I ever do?
Okay, wait.
They can actually do a lot of things.
Never mind.
I was gonna say, what are you going to do?
And I realize, wait, no.
Those two lawyers are actually scary.
I wanna make sure there's nothing here.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew there was something here.
Yay!
I got another Mickey and the Beanstalk.
Is that all of it?
Is it just two guys?
I'm gonna drop this way just in case.
I knew it.
I knew there was something here.
No!
Oh shit.
I'm okay.
How the fuck do I...
How the fuck do I get over there?
Okay, nice.
I knew there was something here.
Beanstalk 3.
I knew my Achievement Hunter jeans.
Jeans smelled something over there.
Alright.
Up I go.
Yay!
What's that sound guy?
Is everything okay now?
The volume?
I don't think I heard the confirmation.
Would you like to travel to slum?
Yeah.
That's cute.
There's a little side-scrolling area.
My gamer senses were tingling.
Hey, it's Gremlin.
Taiso.
What are you doing, Taiso?
Hi, Gus.
Someone sabotaged this door.
It's gonna take paint to fix it.
That's an impressive door.
Definitely Gremlin construction.
Hey, Mickey.
Can you throw paint around?
Why not paint those gears for Taiso?
Yeah.
That'd be great.
I've been working on that Milgear.
So don't break it, please.
Oh.
See?
I did it.
Hooray!
You fixed it!
What the fuck is that?
Oh no.
Did you see that?
It's a nasty thing related to the seers back there.
The metal gear.
That pipe section is sitting out letting steams...
Don't touch the steam.
I'll knock you back.
Please patch those pipes when you see them.
Okay.
Thank you for your help.
Only some of your unique talent for creating paint have done it.
I'll meet you further down the line.
I'm sure of it.
Alright.
We gotta patch the pipes later.
Okay.
Tickets, please.
Now I...
Oh nice!
I knew it.
How's that?
Can I break open these workers' lockers?
Okay.
We go this way.
Paint!
I'm a handyman.
Okay.
Is there anything else I need to delete?
There is again!
We should be able to get...
Go that way too!
But watch your step!
Alright.
From where I can paint my step.
Wait.
Is there something?
Okay, no.
Didn't that big gear...
Or use paint to patch the...
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Well done.
Look, I'm fixing things!
For free!
Yay!
I don't get paid to do this!
Let's grab that.
Nice.
And then that should be everything.
Yay!
Free handyman work!
To pull in a double jump, press A in the middle of a jump.
Well, I've been platforming this entire time.
I know how to double jump, old man.
Oh wait!
Item!
Yay!
Tickets, please!
Guys, it's worth it.
It's item.
What's that over here?
More tickets!
Yes!
Give me all the tickets.
Oh shit!
Oh!
I'm fine.
Okay, more things for me to platform.
Alright.
Um, handyman work is like, very vital and like, um, very expensive now.
Because no one wants to do handyman stuff.
So, uh, I know my words.
Wait, how do I?
Oh, I can't get that.
Wait, that's not supposed to seal something unless there's an emergency.
Let's see.
Is this... a trap?
It is a trap!
Someone shut the door and now a splatter has leaked in here!
Father... Father, please love me!
Look, Father!
I have your ears!
They're really solitary creatures.
Please love me!
Hey!
You splatters?
Peter or Mickey will give you what for.
Why did you abandon us, Father?
Well now, there's no problem with the exit being closed.
Oh!
The gremlin fixed it.
Let me clear the path to this collectible for you.
Enjoy.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Hold on now!
That's Oswald!
Could he have set this trap?
Why does he hate me?
It's not my fault you got abandoned and given to Universal and then I became a multi-million dollar mascot?
It's not my fault!
How is that my fault?
It's not my fault you were here first and then I ended up taking all the glory?
Oh my god, look at all these Mickey's kids!
He's just a hater!
I know, right?
He's such a hater!
Oh my god, it's like Disneyland!
The Guardians of your Track can help you in several ways!
RB and one of your Guardians will race you to your nearest opponent!
But wait, there's more!
RB to launch all of your Guardians!
Unleash sooner!
That'll do the same but with paint!
These ways will disappear!
Alright.
Looks like Gremlin Tim is trapped in a ticket booth!
Oh my god, that's where I get my tickets!
Hey, you over there!
Help me!
Deal with these creatures that trapped me in here, please!
Okay.
Alright.
Father, please!
Oh my god!
Why did Mickey have so many kids?
Mickey!
Why did you have so many children?
Oh my god!
Wait, they're all friends.
We're all friends here.
Are we not?
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
Spatters.
Just because Mickey went easy on you doesn't mean I will...
Beat it!
I'll start those boats for you now!
You can jump on them anytime!
He's...
He's a mouse, Doki.
The Guardians of your Track can help you in several ways.
You can track more by painting or thinning the world around you.
The bar at the top left of your screen shows your progress in interacting with the Guardians.
Each Tecmo bar you complete attracts a new Guardian.
The Guardians exists to help you, Mickey.
Why is anyone's guess?
Okay.
Thank you for taking care of all of the blotlings.
We have time.
There are other riders here that need your help.
I'd love to start a ride, but it seems the machinery is broken.
I need my wrench.
I was working on a spinning cup with a red stripe on top of it when a spatter is attacked.
Haven't seen it since.
If you're willing to help, come see me near the machine behind the elephant ride.
Okay.
Oh, I know what to do with that.
I just break it, right?
That's all I know.
All I know is to break things.
That is my purpose.
Okay.
Pick it.
I don't know what needs to be painted.
Can I remove that?
I can.
Is there anything up here?
Oh, I knew it.
It felt very removable.
All right.
I know, nothing here seems removable.
Oh, wait, Oswald!
There's Oswald's statue.
I mean, I can remove this?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Oh, I can, like, paint the world back.
Oh, that's cute.
I like that.
Oh, wait.
I need this, though.
All right, we paint this.
Oh, my God.
You're an ugly child.
Get out of here.
All right.
Uh...
You know what?
Oswald doesn't deserve this.
Get out of here!
Yeah, I should be nice.
I'll put him in here.
Because I am...
I am a better person.
All right.
Still haven't found it?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure the spinning cup had a red stripe.
I remember because...
Oh!
I have to go to the spinning cup to find it.
Okay.
It should be here.
Uh...
Oh, my God.
This is not safe for kids.
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
This?
You sure this have my...
Oh!
I can make it disappear!
Oh, I see.
I see.
Does that mean there's items in all of these?
Let's see.
No?
All right.
Oh, so if I...
To get the bad ending, I just make this entire world disappear, right?
Yeah, I don't like how there's, like, sharp edges and stuff in it.
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Okay, let's paint this back.
Oh!
Okay, so...
Bad ending, basically, I just delete all their rides.
Yeah, I'll paint these back.
That'll make me a real asshole.
Oh, the game down a little bit?
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, my gosh, the...
I try...
I...
Just using my mouse and the mouse sense is crazy.
Ha, ha, ha!
I was not expecting the mouse sense to be like that.
All right, I brought the game volume...
Down.
My wrench!
Now I can fix the broken elephant ride machine!
Yay!
The spinning cup ride is malfunctioning as well.
All right.
Looks like the pipes behind the maintenance area walls are leaking.
That's my guess.
Non-flying types like you can use the elephant ride to jump up on the...
big tent.
From there, you can reach the maintenance area.
It's a difficult path, but you seem to be capable.
It'll be me.
I'll be over behind the spinning cup ride, examining the machine.
That's right.
Nothing is impossible for me.
Uh-huh!
Cause I'm gaming...
Okay, wait.
Cause I'm gaming!
Take me up there, Dumbo!
That's fucking right.
Okay.
As I was saying...
Cause I'm gaming!
There's no seat belts on this.
Even better!
Okay, nice.
We got it.
It should be around.
Here.
Oh!
I should've been...
I was supposed to...
Jump here.
Oops!
Let's fix this area real quick.
I can go here.
Wait, what does this do?
Oh.
Okay, that doesn't need to be fixed though.
Let's get the creepy dolls out of here first.
Now stop rotating!
Pain will start it again!
Okay, so...
Like that?
Okay, yeah.
Maybe not like that.
A bad ending.
Okay, nice.
Oh wait, there's a collectible down here.
Uh...
I'll get it later.
Cause I feel like I have to do this first.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh my god, there was a little gap.
I didn't notice the little gap.
Okay.
This has to be the...
Standard equipment on most rides.
It can be filled with either paint or thinner, but never both at the same time.
Paint often thinks things up.
Get the ride running smoother.
Thinner attempts to throw a wrench in the works.
Sometimes that's handy, though.
A paint and thinner pump is always connected to something.
This one's connected to a spinning cup ride.
In this case, it's connected with two pipes.
Filling it with thinner may have unexpected consequences.
Okay, guys.
Can I fix things?
If I... I need to know.
Is it fixable if I...
If I accidentally fuck it up?
Can I have an oopsie moment?
Turkey, think long and hard.
Which pink you wanna use?
Okay.
But Kevin's like, oopsie.
Okay, I won't fill it with thinner.
You fixed the ride!
That makes me feel much better.
In fact, so much better that I can open this door for you.
My bad, bro.
I'll be like, oops, my bad.
Boys will be boys.
In fact, so much better that I can open this door for you.
Please, keep whatever you may find in there, along with my gratitude.
Okay, fine.
I...
I won't...
I won't accidentally...
Use thinner.
Uh...
Let's see.
Let's grab my collectible.
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's the boat.
Oh, I have to go to that boat later.
What did he open for me?
This?
Oh, that's what he opened.
Hello.
What's in here?
Oh!
Nice!
Alright, sound, guys.
So, overall volume a lot better now.
Tickets!
Yay!
Tickets, please.
Okay.
Overall, just...
You know, I could just do it in the master, actually.
Uh...
Alright, uh...
Actually, no.
I feel like master volume is, like, super sensitive when I do it here.
Um, and I'll just turn it down from...
From my OBS.
Might be easier.
Alright, before I play...
Give me a sec, I need to grab tissues.
Cause I need to blow my nose.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I got it.
It was like next to me.
So, pretty easy to grab.
Alright, I'm ready.
Okay, I fixed that.
Am I done fixing things?
Oh, wait, what's this?
Okay, so that's where I'm supposed to go.
And I...
Did I fix it?
Did I save this world?
I did it.
I'm a hero.
Alright, I should be able to...
Go for it now.
I think I fixed the world.
I've been...
I'm ready...
I'm ready to start...
The actual mission.
I'm ready to beat up Oswald.
That's fucking right.
Get back here.
There's a reason why...
Dad abandoned you and kept me.
Yay!
Our hero.
Alright.
Wish this boat ride was a little faster though.
That's right.
I'm the favorite child.
Well, this ride isn't fixed at all.
Look at those boats jammed in there.
Some are even overturned.
The doors should automatically open.
But I guess it's broken too.
There are pipes inside the walls that operate the door locks.
Leading out those pipes will break the locks and the door should open.
Now that I think of it, the hippos are connected to the door as well.
Stopping the hippos with paint will bypass the door locks and that would open it too.
Okay, so...
Obviously, I have to paint.
I have to paint it.
Okay.
Because we have to do...
We have to be good.
Because that's the Disney way.
Don't wanna make Mickey into a psychopathic murderer or anything.
Or he destroyed...
That's actually crazy.
The bad ending is him like fucking destroying this...
This universe.
That's actually...
But that's no fun, Doki!
Like...
I'm like, holy shit, Mickey's a psychopath.
I'm not trying to go evil.
Look over there.
You did it!
Mickey becomes a fucking psychopathic murderer.
He's here to fuck destroy your multiverse.
It does sound a little...
Kinda fun.
Okay.
But which ending is the best better ending?
Evil Mickey Arc will go hard.
And they didn't want the genocider out.
They shouldn't have kidnapped Mickey.
Maybe the one word in the world doesn't get deleted.
What's that noise?
That's a whirlpool!
Stay clear of those!
Just think.
We have stayed on the boats too long.
Uh-oh.
That creature ahead looks like a sweeper.
They're in trouble.
They're cousins of the spiders.
Are capable of hurling bucketfuls of thinner.
If you get too close, he'll try to sweep you into the river.
Hence the name, Sweeper.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll force him to be my friend.
FRIEND!
I did it.
Oh my god!
He helps paint too!
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, did I miss something?
What did I miss?
Oh wait!
The collectible.
Friendship.
Aggressively becomes your friend.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go now?
Oh, do I go in the whirlpool?
Where else can I go?
Oh.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, that was...
I don't know, I just...
Oh my god, there's something here.
I just don't...
A whole...
A whole second!
Goal!
Much better!
Gremlins Hyperion!
Peanut and Habba!
Are still a cage somewhere.
Any of us you can help will return the favor at the first opportunity.
I'm sorry!
I don't know!
I saw a hole!
I was like...
I think I can survive that.
I think...
That's survivable.
What's that?
How'd that chest get up here?
There must be a way...
To get it.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Reminds to subscribe to Doki.
Like the stream or leave a comment on the VOD YouTube.
YouTube apparently not acknowledge you as a viewer.
Oh wait, really?
I didn't know that.
I didn't know they like...
That's fucking dumb though.
Cause you know, people like to lurk.
That's stupid that they like, made it so that...
You have to interact.
Alright, let's see.
I mean, it's good for a YouTube for advertisers.
But some people just want to lurk.
I mean, I'm a lurker.
Okay, how do I...
Okay, we're gonna do this.
Okay, I'll thin this.
And then...
I'll do this.
Thin this.
How do I get to that one though?
That one's so far.
Oh, so if you like...
Oh, if you like it, then you don't have to worry.
Oh, that's good.
I'm glad.
I mean, I like liking the video won't like pressure you guys to...
To like comment and stuff.
Cause if you wanna lurk, that's fine with me.
As long as you guys watch, have fun, enjoy yourself.
And let...
Make sure I don't commit murder on these...
On these people that live in this world.
And everything will be fine.
That was not an easy chest to reach.
I'm impressed.
Okay.
Go this way.
Bruh, it's like Mickey was gonna Thanos...
This universe if I...
If I decided to be a little bad.
Yay!
Bronze pin!
Yippee!
Okay.
Let's go this way.
I fell down.
Thank you for the five.
Get the chips.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Wait.
That's it?
What else am I supposed to do in this world?
Oh, maybe the red door.
My conscience is like, Don't erase them.
Don't accidentally erase the entire world.
Don't do it, Doki.
This is Jiminy Cricket here.
I'm your conscience.
I'm like, Oh, but it'll be so fun.
But I could just...
Oh, I could just do it right now.
It's just right there.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
How do I get back?
Oh, this way.
Oh, fuck.
I have to do this all over again.
Just for the little funsies.
Okay.
Okay, though.
But like, how many little oopsie accidents can I do before...
Okay.
Do I have to be good all the time?
Or can I make like, you know, one...
You know, maybe a little accident.
Where someone actually disappears.
Like, how many...
How many oopsies can you have?
Like, little accidents.
Alright, friends.
Let's see.
Some accidental murders.
I am in your debt.
I hope you can help my other trapped friends.
I will express my gratitude when an opportunity presents itself.
Oh, 75%?
Okay.
Wait.
Surely a few won't hurt, right?
Sure.
Just a little treat.
Just to see how it's like.
Um, rest...
Welcome to...
No, don't do it!
Don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it.
Don't do it.
This sentence happens.
Look at this guy.
I didn't do anything.
He fell.
You guys saw it.
We both fell.
Carp, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Algorithm, maddenated, super.
Also, it's my birthday today.
Can I get a happy birthday from my Kami Ocean?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vlad.
Yeah!
There was no murder.
I didn't do anything.
He and I both fell.
And I just couldn't save him, guys.
I tried so hard.
I said, Grab my hand, son.
And he was like, No, father.
You have to live.
You have so much more to live for.
Go live your life.
And then I was like, No, son!
And here we are.
And then here we are.
Minsa is grateful.
I'm right behind you.
Let's go.
Oh!
It was... So sad.
Thoughts and prayers for my...
My dead son.
I too am a witness.
I confirmed that this is precisely what happened.
Alright, let's see.
How do I get that?
Okay, nice.
Woo!
I'll grab... You know what?
I can just send that in.
It's like an instant friendship theme.
And I can't please get five big booms.
Um...
Child, thank you for the super chat.
Uh...
Thank you.
VTuber version of your brain telling you to step off when you're near a really high edge.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just wanted to go down here.
I wanna grab this real quick.
What's this?
Oh, it's a gear.
Okay.
Get rid of these ugly dolls.
Not in my Disneyland.
Okay, wait.
Nah.
Okay.
It doesn't register as something yet.
Alright, so I have to go down.
Here, I assume?
The sweepers are on a retractable platform.
Use the valves to drop them onto the thinner.
And open the doors.
Pencils to the rescue.
My trusty wrench will clear the road.
Oh my...
Okay, I was gonna say.
I didn't commit that murder.
That wasn't me.
Get a return of favor.
Watch.
Oh my god.
I didn't do that.
That wasn't me.
No.
We all saw him.
He fell in there on his own.
No, I wasn't the one that did the murder this time.
As in like, I never did any murders at all.
It was him!
He did it!
Is he friends yet?
He is, right?
Okay.
We're all friends now.
You were an accomplice.
Like, am I...
I feel like I shouldn't activate this.
I clipped that.
I was just a spectator!
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, how do we get that?
Oh.
Oh, I see.
We have to do the...
Wait, no?
Which one was for that one?
Cause that one...
I assume...
Is...
Oh my god.
I feel like if I...
Is this?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, but how do I use the valve?
What?
How would I use the valve?
Open that.
You broke him out of his prison.
Okay.
Try the valve.
Here.
Cause I wanna get this, but...
How can I get that?
A wall?
Oh, this wall?
There's nothing in that wall.
Just a regular wall.
See?
Oh, shit.
Nevermind.
Guys, it wasn't just a regular wall.
Guys.
Wait, what?
But I could've just jumped there.
Guys, look at that.
But where do I go after here?
Wait, what?
What do you do after here?
What?
I'm just...
Stuck here.
Oh my god.
Please, please, please.
Okay.
Wait, what?
I'm so confused.
There's like nothing else here.
It just goes...
How do I retract that wall, though?
Eh?
Okay.
Oh, I killed the guy that...
Yeah.
Me.
Okay.
I killed...
That was not my fault.
We all saw what happened, guys.
Why didn't thin that?
No, you can't thin this.
See?
It's not thinable.
It's so weird.
Okay, that guy did not help me.
That guy like, made us worse.
I can't...
Dash?
Is that...
There's no way.
There has to be a way to...
Figure this out.
Because I can't do any of these parts.
Toki, why did you kill that guy?
It wasn't me!
I swear to god!
Oh my god!
Oh, he's safe!
He's...
No!
Oh my gosh!
They're kidding!
Guys, I swear to god, it wasn't me.
Guys, I swear...
I swear to god, I didn't do it.
I...
It wasn't me, guys!
I swear to god!
It was just...
You all saw it!
It was an accident.
We all saw...
He had his airpods on.
Guys...
I tried to save him!
Oh, now I'm stuck.
Guys, he had his airpods on.
Guys...
I wanted to save him!
Oh my god.
I don't think I can do this.
I tried to save him, guys.
I really did.
No!
He didn't follow safety regulations.
There's no going back!
Might have to come back.
And then the guy was like, there's no going back.
There's no...
I finally had to shut the steam up.
The entrance to the...
Asia boat riders through that door.
There has to be something around here that can help.
Okay.
I don't know exactly how much time this is, so I wanna make sure.
Alright.
Okay.
I assume I have to shut everything down.
In a time manner.
Oh, hey!
That's Pete.
Female Pete.
Small Pete.
Mickey Mouse, eh?
I hear you're in Mr. Goody Two-Shoes.
Mom, here's your chance to prove it.
I spent years getting a lot of gremlins.
Only I have to knock him around on occasion.
Then the one time I crashed my boat into their village.
They seem to think I'm some kind of villain.
Not that I give two hoots what they think.
But, it was...
See?
It was an accident.
He knows what's up.
Pete's the most reliable guy.
He's a good father.
And my ship's logs will prove it.
Those little monsters will let me near the wreck together, though.
Hmm?
I bet they'll let you.
Find that log from my ship, so we can put this to rest.
And I can get back to work.
See ya soon.
Or sooner.
If you know what's good for ya.
See, guys?
Pete knows what's up.
We all know Pete is very...
...reliable.
Good ol' Pete.
Hear me out.
Oh, shit.
I saw a gremlin bra on top of the pagoda.
Perhaps he can tell us how to follow Oswald.
Bra might also have a grasp on whatever small Pete was complaining about.
That's Oswald again.
How did he get over there?
Surely didn't lock that door.
Stupid Oswald.
I'm gonna get him.
Yeah, he's just misunderstood, guys.
Pete's just misunderstood.
Alright, let's get him out.
Bring him out.
Now we're friends.
Yay!
Oh wait, there's some items here.
I want that.
Tickets!
What do I do with these tickets?
Alright.
Let's see.
Yay!
We're friends now.
See?
Look at that.
If I committed murder, why would they want to be friends with me?
If I, quote on quote, killed their other friends.
If you think about it.
Checkmate.
Oh well, I guess you're not a partner of small Pete.
They didn't know.
They don't want to...
They don't want to be next.
The boats will take you to the island, but not much further.
Don't stay on too long.
There's some machinery over there.
I happen to know what it does.
It controls something called a fire bridge.
Here's the name for a bridge.
That is your key to escape here.
The really tricky part is getting to the machinery.
You're gonna face some challenges there.
Alright, I can parkour that.
Oh, nice.
Oh, can I become friends with him yet?
No, but I can...
No, I can't.
I was gonna shoot my goo over there.
Alright, we gotta go this way then.
Okay, we'll go this way first.
And then destroy these tickets.
Don't worry, I'll help you very soon, little guy.
Just gotta destroy these creepy dolls.
And then I'll free you.
Okay.
Alright.
Looks like the whirlpool sank the boat you're on.
You can fix it.
So you can reach the gears.
But those dolls behind the big walls are complicated.
It's either just paying me to do it.
Just because I'm free does not mean my wrench...
See, I told... Look at that!
Look at that.
Fucking handyman trying to scam me right now.
Its help requires a small fee.
Alright, yeah.
Fix it.
I'll endeavor to provide 100% satisfaction, sir.
Look at that.
See?
He charges for his work.
Alright.
Just gonna apply a bit of wrench action here.
Yeah?
Now, it should be working to your satisfaction.
Wait, which one did you...
Prepare?
Already lost.
Oh, it's over here.
I see it.
I was like, what did he do?
What did you do?
How do I fix it then?
What the fuck am I supposed to...
Bro, what?
How am I supposed to fix this?
Oh my god.
Oh fuck, I thought I was aiming.
What are you doing?
I have to go through here.
Wait, do I?
Bro, I have to go...
Bro, bro, stop!
Stop!
This is where I have to go!
He's like, I...
I'm your friend now.
Let me block the exit.
Okay, it's down here.
Alright.
Oh, so that's what he did.
Pretty old though.
Okay.
Okay, it's time.
Okay, it's five seconds.
They're helping you.
They're just trying to help.
Okay, I just want to know how long it was before I do it.
Oh shit, ow.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
Okay, I can...
I have to get rid of this.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, come on.
Okay, nice.
Let's go check out that red chest over here.
I wonder what it could be.
What did I unlock?
Where am I?
Okay, I gotta fix this.
So it doesn't look like I...
did something wrong.
Okay.
I can get rid of this.
And then...
jump through here.
Parkour!
FRIEND!
There we go.
Yay!
Force friendship!
Let's...
GO!
There we go.
I got the chest.
My friend...
My friend goop.
Yay!
Bronze pin.
Let's go.
My friend...
It's like the Care Bear stair.
One, two, three, four.
What is it?
How does the Care Bear stair go again?
Ha ha ha.
Care Bear stair!
My friend goop.
It's like Care Bear stair.
I'm giving them friendship.
Okay.
Okay, that's just fine.
What is that?
There's a chest over here.
But I didn't get the chairs.
Care Bears.
Count down.
Four, three, two, one.
Yeah!
That's basically it.
I just did that!
What do I do now?
Oh, I didn't go that way yet.
I had to do something here.
Yeah.
I was like, oh, I didn't go this way.
Oh, hey.
Achievement.
Or, collectible.
Okay, uh...
Okay, that.
I got rid of this.
Then I climbed this.
Oh shit, what?
What did I do?
Oh my god, that's a dragon!
Oh shit!
Oh, that's so cool!
We will be friends.
Do not resist!
Okay, nice.
I can go to the tempo now.
Where does this go?
Where the fuck does this go, though?
What?
Oh, it goes straight to this, but...
I can't unlock that yet.
Okay, I was like, so confused.
I was like, what?
Where's the switch for that?
Oh, is that a good dragon?
Oh, there's a bad dragon?
Wait, that dragon actually changes too?
Because I've been a good person this entire game.
I mean...
El, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Hi Toki, I think I need to rest.
Since I feel a migraine coming.
Oh, I hope you get better soon.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I hope you get better soon.
Your health is much more important.
I paid the guy to fix a fucking gear?
And I don't even know what he fixed.
Like...
What did he do?
I don't even know.
I don't even know what he did for me.
I reached the exit.
But how come the door doesn't open?
Try getting up to this level on the other side of the door.
The fact is, they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Here's some money.
I like money.
Okay, there's that.
And then there's that.
We got the clouds.
I don't know how to get up there though.
Oh, okay.
Now it comes up.
Okay.
I was like, how do I get up?
Oh, levitating.
Oh, I don't like the faces they're making.
Oh.
Parkour.
Oh!
Nice!
I unlocked Steamboat Willie!
Did it!
The door is opening!
Is there anything else up here?
Oh, there's bad people over there.
How do I get there?
I wanna say hi to the bad people.
And make them my friends.
Alright.
Let's see.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
You will become my friend!
Oh, shit!
Friend!
That's right!
Do not resist!
Oh my god, bro!
Stop hitting him!
He's friend!
Okay.
I don't know what this does.
Oh, shit!
It was an accident!
You all saw that, right?
That was...
Guys!
That was an accident!
He and we...
It was a work...
Zero days since the last work place accident!
No!
I didn't kill him!
I swear!
It was like final destination, guys!
His death was...
His death was already decided!
Oh my god!
Am I glad to be free of that cage?
Cramps one leg!
I can tell you!
It was all Osha's fault!
Oh, we already...
Wait, we already reached him, though.
Let's let anyone ask...
Let me know that I'm...
Guys!
We all saw it, right?
His death was already decided!
It was...
It was a final destination death!
That's why...
One life in exchange for his freedom!
I swear to god!
Let's grab that!
I got everything here!
What was the point of needing this area?
Oh, I guess I could've picked which one I wanted to do!
Okay, but I wanted to do left or right!
It was a necessary sacrifice!
Yeah, cause I'm like thinking, how do I get that chest over there?
Alright, let's go!
Let's jump in!
Yeah, I'm ready to go in the world of gremlins!
Rebellions!
Thank you!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome!
Yo, what's in here?
Oh, I knew it!
Oh, nice!
Money!
Oh my god!
I love the classic steamboat movie!
Oh look!
There's evil Pete!
I mean, good Pete!
You know?
Cause we're good friends!
Alright, I wanna go up though!
It's good Pete!
Cause he understands me!
What does this do?
Wait...
Does it pull me up?
Oh yeah, it does!
Nice!
Okay...
Go this way...
I was like, oh my god!
It's like Bendy!
You shut your mouth right now!
Okay, wait, I need to go...
Wait...
Oh, I need to go up here!
Is this...
Oh my god!
I can't believe!
Epic Mickey took inspiration from Bendy, guys!
Alright!
Okay, I have to go this way then.
Alright, this way.
Oh, I already played Ink Machine.
Unfortunately, the archives...
I mean, you can still find the archives of it, but...
Yeah.
I already played Bendy and the Ink Machine, and also...
Uh...
The sequel.
Okay, nice.
Yay!
The film!
Part 1?
Where the fuck is part 2?
I can't even...
What?
Alright.
I don't know where part 2 is.
Is part 2 even here?
Or am I gonna go back to Steamboat?
Oh, fuck it, let's go.
You're in Lost Media!
Yeah, I'm ready to enter.
Paint for the Paint God!
Boom!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Now I'm in the Gremlin world.
I'm gonna steal their money.
Oh, it's...
The world is pretty ugly.
This is our village, but it's been a...
Yeah, I was gonna say, the world...
Definitely does not look the best.
Our wonderful village tower and windmill are ruined!
Pipes leaking everywhere!
The pipes here used to power the entire village!
We gotta get them patched up!
My house!
What happened to it?
That thinner is ruining my lovely house!
Please, save our village!
Alright, save...
Okay, good thing they don't know I was the reason why the village just fucked up.
I was the OG problem!
But they don't know!
Here, I'll fix that.
Hello!
The pipes here used to power the entire village!
We got to get them patched up!
Please, save...
Don't worry, I'll be a hero!
You don't know it was me that caused all this!
So you'll think I'm the hero!
Okay, I'll get that.
And then...
Yeah, I'm the problem, but I also sell the miracle solution.
It's like I poison the water, and I'll be like, Don't worry, guys!
I have the solution for all of that!
I hold the only antidote to the poisoned water!
What a coincidence, guys!
I patched up now!
Nice work!
Look for the valve controls!
Spin them right off!
Okay, to this one.
I'm a hero!
It's like, look, it's like you fixed it!
Now you can fix my house!
And look!
Those rides are working again, too!
We can use them to...
Uh...
Get around the village!
It's tricky, but I have confidence in you!
Thank you for fixing those pipes!
Can you fix the village tower as well?
There is a pump up there that can operate the gate!
All right.
Yeah, we can fix that.
What's he doing here?
See what happened here?
Small P was showing up and crashed his boat into our village!
Pete says he didn't do it on purpose, but I don't believe him!
He's been such a bully in the past, you know!
Until I see if evidence that really was an accident, we gremlins will keep him out of the village!
Oh, come on!
It's a little oopsie!
Everyone has little oopsies, guys!
Right, guys?
Just a little oopsie!
Bush, thank you for the super chat!
Welcome to tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Accidents happen, everyone!
Oh, nice!
Lots of money!
Yay!
Is there anything here?
Other than money?
That's right, I'm greedy!
He's...
He said he's sorry!
Sorry I spilled the oil in the ocean!
I'm...
I'm sorry!
Okay.
I got that house.
Okay, let's get his house, too.
Okay.
Save this house.
We did it!
Thank you so much!
I'll talk to the other gremlins.
Everyone will know about what you've done for me here.
Alright, nice.
Fix that.
Thank you for saving Gus's house, Mickey!
Huh?
Oh boy!
No problem!
Okay, we'll go this way.
Where's the...
The ship.
So I can clear Pete's name.
For the sake of both of us.
I'm not doing it for him.
Wait, no, I'm doing it for him because I care about him.
Guys.
It's not for any selfish reasons.
Oh my god, this guy has security cameras in his own home.
This guy's paranoid as fuck.
The swamp Pete situation is crazy.
Hahaha!
I'm not like...
I don't need to...
Uh...
Yeah, I don't need to...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, how do I actually get up there?
Oh shit, whoops.
I can't...
Yeah, I can tank that.
Yeah, how the fuck?
How do I get up there actually?
Wait, let me rob this guy's house real quick.
Yay!
Sorry, I meant borrow.
I'm just borrowing some money.
Tickets, please.
Oh yeah, no.
The platforming is really smooth here.
Ah!
Sorry.
Hahaha.
It's not a thing.
I didn't know, burn me!
Okay.
How do I get to...
Are you...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Okay, how do I get up there?
Like...
Like, I can't...
There's no way.
Oh, I do make it.
Okay, I couldn't tell that if I would make it or not.
It's so hard to tell.
Okay, we gotta find the logs.
That's me in here.
Okay, there's the logs.
Green is a dangerous color.
Alright.
Alright, I got his log book.
Don't worry, Pete.
I'm gonna clear your innocence.
Just like any good friend would do.
I told you guys he was a good person.
He's just misunderstood.
Oh, it says here in the log that the crash was an accident.
And small...
Dear Diary, I didn't do it.
And then you submit that as evidence in the court of law.
I didn't do it.
And I feel bad about it.
I didn't know he had feelings.
I'll let the other grievous know it was all misunderstanding.
Oh, yay!
I'm seeing you in a hole.
Not guilty.
And I...
In the court of law, we...
In the court of law, we judge thee not guilty.
I didn't believe it when he said it.
But now that he wrote it down, it's undeniable.
Sorry, I can't open the skate.
I don't mean I won't.
I mean I can't.
The pump that controls the door is at the top of the village tower.
Use that pump to get the gates functioning.
Let's get this house back first.
Your honor, my client pleads.
Oopsie.
Wait, there's something over here.
Is there?
Oh, no, there isn't.
In the court of law, I peed.
I felt really bad, though, when it happened.
Thank you again for freeing me from Dark Beauty Castle.
I was looking for a way to show my appreciation.
I came up with this.
Wait, what did he came up with?
What did he came up with?
What was it?
I don't even know what it was.
My client pleads.
Whoopsie dokes.
Whoopsie daisy.
What the fuck did he do?
Oh, he gave me money?
Oh, nice.
Okay, I take those.
That's fucking right.
Give me the money.
Let's give him this house back, too.
So, you sure the ship's locked to Bennett?
Well, now I can't treat...
I didn't...
What?
You would have given me the pin?
Why did I know I could...
Oh, my God.
I didn't know there was another guy that wanted it.
That's fucked up.
I can't believe it.
I lost...
I lost an achievement.
I can't believe it.
Why would you be here?
I would not talk to you first.
Why were you all the way up here?
Thank you for fixing this pipe.
Can you fix the village tower as well?
Okay, I'll paint this guy's home first.
Oh, why not?
What about Pete's innocence?
What about my pin?
My achievements!
Okay, nice.
Oh, money.
The cost of betrayal of pin.
That's all it takes, huh, Doki?
Yes.
My pin collection ruined!
How else?
What would the other...
Actually, is there a name for those pin collectors anyway?
What would they say about me?
If I don't come back with the exclusive pin?
How will I show my face to them?
What?
Oh, shit!
Run!
Guys, that was a...
It's called a friendship slap, okay?
It was a friendship slap, guys.
Thank you for getting out of here, Mickey.
It was fogging up.
You're fake collecting.
I'll enable that projector screen behind you.
It's a secret shortcut to the European boat ride.
Don't tell anyone.
Did I not fix it?
Wait, but I gotta fix the...
The tower.
Did I fix it?
I can't tell.
All right.
Uh...
No.
Wait, what?
I thought I fixed it.
I have friends now.
Oh, there's something here.
Oh...
Okay, if I didn't fix it, then what do I have to do?
Maybe up here?
Oh!
That's the tower I have to fix.
Oh, shit!
It's okay, I can tank it.
Okay.
And I'll tank it, and then I'll go on my...
I can show you the world.
It still surprised me that my friend liked Kingdom Hearts, because they had no nostalgia feeling going into it.
Because Kingdom Hearts 1 was definitely fueled by nostalgia bait.
I already traveled to the top of the village tower?
Yeah.
All right.
What did I do?
Oh, nice.
I'm gonna go up.
Up I go!
Take me up.
Oh!
Oh, that's such a cute mechanic!
Okay, I like that.
When you run, it goes up.
Oh, I like that.
That's cute.
Get up!
Wake up!
Okay.
Just wanna grab the tickets here first.
That's so smart.
I miss when they...
Oh, I miss when Disney...
They used to do the, like, actual creative Disney games.
Um...
The Disney Studios.
But, like, they stopped focusing on games.
For a while.
I don't remember who would...
Was it what?
It was Bob Agner?
That wasn't him?
We had to...
They had to...
Like, say, Wii.
Disney, at one point, did, like, a full investment.
And, um...
In Disney games.
Like, actual Disney games.
Because they're, like...
Oh, that's, like, the next, like...
Um...
The next venture into, like...
What's it called?
The next venture into, like, creative...
Properties and stuff.
And they decided to make, like, video games and stuff for all their Disney properties.
And then, like...
And then that ended and everybody...
And now they're, like...
Move...
Live-action movie time!
Yeah, next venture into, like...
The next big thing for Disney.
They had...
Had so many good games, too.
Wow!
Whoops.
Okay.
No!
Put me up!
Eat me up!
Oh, is it Bob Eisner?
I don't...
Yeah, I don't remember the name.
Of the Disney studios.
There's so many.
Block cleaners.
Part one.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Yeah.
That's why, like...
They want to shut the Disney game studios down.
We...
They just, like...
Outsourged their game production to different studios.
I don't know any, like, recent good Disney game that came up.
Okay.
Can I have one oopsie, though?
Guys, they're, like...
Oh, my God!
Mickey fixed everything!
Lose a paint and thinner pump.
Standard equipment on most rides.
It can be filled with...
Why would you tell me about the thinner part?
For your fucking village.
Like...
Like, it's like...
This is my village!
Anyway, you could destroy it!
They did it!
The exit gate is open!
Alright, we open the gate.
I mean, you could, but you won't, right, Mickey?
Yeah, you won't do that!
Yeah.
Does that mean I could?
Okay, so this is...
Steamboat Willie's scene too.
But what about over there?
That's the thing.
Like...
Can I go to the tower now for that?
I want to check this real quick.
The clock, you know.
What is that area?
Like, why would I have to do this area?
I'm so confused.
Okay.
Let's do this one.
Alright.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
What?
I have unfinished quests?
Where are my unfinished quests?
Yeah.
I already did everything.
Okay.
Maybe unfinished quests here, but we might not be able to return.
I already entered the European boat ride.
Yes.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah!
Oh, this is scene two?
Oh, this is scene two!
Okay.
I love scene two, really, son.
Such a clap.
Oh my god, it's you!
Fuck you!
I hated this goat.
This...
Oh, what Disney game is it?
Was it on the...
Oh, I don't remember which one it was.
But...
There was a...
Um...
An old Disney game with that goat in it.
And then I always died to that goat.
But I could never remember exactly...
Was it the mirror one?
Was it the one with the...
Mirror?
I don't remember.
But there's that goat.
I'll always remember that goat.
I got beef with that goat.
Is it Castle of Illusions?
It's the one with their world.
It's like pixel art.
I don't remember.
But fuck this goat.
Fuck you!
I always died to that goat.
Little me would always die to that goddamn goat.
I'll never forget.
I don't know if it's...
I don't know if it's Castle...
Oh, it could be Castle of Illusion.
It was a pixel game.
Doki never forgets.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Oh my god.
There's little boys down there.
This is the Europe area.
Oh, it's like a whole new world.
No, not a whole new world.
It's like...
What is it called?
Small world!
It's a small world!
Look at that leaning tower.
I hope it doesn't fall.
Every year, the tower leans a little bit.
You guys know that?
Just a tiny little bit.
One day it's actually...
I feel like one day it's gonna fucking fall.
Hey god.
It leans more and more every year.
Until it can't lean no more.
These pillars look like they could topple over with a sneeze.
Friends!
Do not resist friendship!
Do not resist!
We are friends!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Wait, it feels like there's something behind this.
Yeah, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I saw that little peek.
Do not be afraid!
We shall become best friends!
Hey, what's over here?
Money!
Alright, let's grab all that money.
We do maintenance to make sure it's stable.
It's still...
It's still like...
Oh, get inside the coliseum.
It still...
It still leans a little bit, though.
That's the scary part.
Friends.
Hey!
Does it move?
Uh...
How's that?
I didn't give you the super chat.
Thank you.
Anything back?
Yeah?
Oh, there is.
Oh, there's something behind there.
I knew it.
I knew there was something back here.
I like how it keeps giving me the green paint.
They're like, you know you want to do it, Doki.
Come on.
Just a little bit.
Stop tensing me!
It's like the apple.
It's like, come on, take a bite, Doki.
Take a bite from that apple.
Use the thinner you know you want to.
I guess someone in my chat was like, please don't do the bad ending.
I never got to see it as a kid.
That means you were also a bad kid!
You have to live with your consequences.
These support beams are tuned or not.
I know what you did, child.
No, you were a sinner.
Oh my god, are you...
Wait, actually, I never did anything on this side of the map.
I should, like, check that out.
Wait, how did I get to this?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
Because I realized I actually didn't do a lot from the main area.
I just went on my side quest here.
Oh.
Oh my god, I bought...
Guys, I swear to god, I didn't do anything bad.
I swear...
I don't get...
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize that I wasn't supposed to do that.
I was like, oh, that's...
That's funny.
Vandalism.
We saw what you did.
We know what you did.
Oh no, I got the evil spirit now.
It's okay.
I get, like...
We still get the good ending.
I just did one accident, guys.
You heard what they said.
I can always...
I just have one accident.
Look at that.
I'm fixing everything, guys.
I'm fixing everything.
Look at me go.
I'm fixing stuff, guys.
I'm a good person.
I'm fixing stuff.
Look at me go.
Whoa.
Look at everything.
I'm fixing.
Yeah.
All right.
There's, like, something up here, though.
I'm just checking, I'm just checking, I'm just checking.
Yeah, see, there's, like, how do I... there's, like, something up there.
How do I get up there?
What's this?
Okay, I completed the Leaning Tower.
But what did I do?
But what did I do, though?
Alright.
Uhhh...
It's a small world after all.
Ba-da-bum-bum-bum.
Okay.
I'll go back up here.
Oh my god.
I fucked up the parkour.
Oh!
I did.
Let me up!
Yay!
Okay.
Okay, as long as I...
Oh my god, where's the support?
Oh!
Oh my god, who would have thought the Eiffel Tower has a hole in the middle?
Okay, we'll do that.
No, I was...
I didn't look down.
Okay.
Let's try to figure something out.
Like, how do I...
How am I supposed to get up?
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, now that's how it...
Okay, nice.
I was like, so confused.
I was like, how am I supposed to...
fix the Eiffel Tower?
Oh, I don't fix it.
It's already fixed.
Right?
Like...
Is Eiffel Tower fixed already?
I can't tell.
I assume it's fixed, right?
Cause there's like, nothing I'm supposed to get?
Yeah.
There's no like, thing I'm supposed to turn here.
You mean the Eiffel Tower?
Ha ha ha!
Did you get that?
Topple the...
To find an alternative path to the Colosseum.
Topple the Parisian Tower?
That seems like me breaking something.
Okay.
We don't need that.
It's one ticket, guys.
We don't need it.
It's literally one ticket.
Oh, there...
Oh!
It's over here.
Okay.
Okay, so we have to get into the Colosseum.
Oh, that's a scary tiger mouth thing.
How do we...
I assume it's the boat ride then.
Doesn't seem like...
Oh!
If I want to be a bad person, I'll remove the support beams.
Yeah, I have to find another route.
But we're not bad people, guys.
Okay, I know where the...
I know where the alternative route is.
So...
Let's see.
How do we get to the actual...
I know where the bad route is.
So we need to find the...
Good route.
Wherever the good route is.
Where the fuck is the good route?
So I can be a good person.
I'm here.
I am a good person.
My god, where is it?
Where is it?
No.
I'm gonna try out...
The Paris place again.
There has to be an alternative route here somewhere.
Okay.
Cause I'm like...
Yeah, press that button.
Maybe like...
Yeah?
Huh?
No, that just paints it back.
So we have to find a way to...
Maybe get over from this side?
Maybe?
I'm not stuck, guys.
I'm just trying to be a good...
I can do the evil thing!
But I won't!
I won't do the evil thing!
I'm trying to do the good thing!
Okay.
The alternative path is like...
This way.
How the fuck do I get there?
No, it's not the boats.
I'm pretty sure it's not the boats.
Is it a plane?
Oh wait, there is!
Oh my god, you're right!
Watch this.
I mean...
Okay.
I mean, that worked.
Oh my god, it's over here.
I found it.
There we go.
Easy.
Now we're friends.
Okay.
Figure it out.
Okay, I need to...
Open this chest real...
Oh, never mind.
I assume...
That's where I have to go.
That's right.
I took the leap of faith because I believed.
I'm a believer.
Let's see...
Oh shit.
I knew I wouldn't make that jump if I fucked that up.
What's over here?
I saw like...
Yeah, I saw like the thing over here.
What show is this?
What?
Oh, maybe that was like for the alternative path.
From the clock tower.
Okay, I got the shortcut here.
And I saw her face but...
Now I'm a believer.
Alright, this way.
Oh!
How does Toki play with one hand and make a Twitter post with the other?
Is this what...
Wait, did I make a Twitter post?
Did I...
Did I schedule something?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh, my...
Oh, me!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I'm just a gamer.
I was like, oh my god.
Did I actually schedule something?
I had to appear.
I was like, oh my god.
Did I accidentally made a tweet?
I'm just gaming.
That's really it.
I'm just that good.
That was actually a fear.
I was like, fear.
Did I accidentally...
Okay, there we go.
Open up!
My quail!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, a silver pin.
Nice.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Keep forgetting about gravity.
Okay, yeah, we're not getting that.
Alright, nice.
Make that jump.
Then we make this jump.
And that's how you do it.
Okay, but how do you get that, though?
Let me in.
Let me in!
Okay, we got the alternate path.
Look at that.
We didn't destroy any...
European structures.
Hey, Mickey.
Look at that girl.
You did it!
I might have misjudged you, but watch out, cuz my cousin over on Mean Street makes me seem like a cuddly little kitten.
Oh, and help yourself to some treasure!
As for me, time to go!
Let me go!
I didn't destroy any historical...
artifacts!
Oh, a room full!
Oh, that's how I get it!
Nice!
Wait, how do I get to that room, though?
Back here?
You, like, teleported me...
in the front!
Fucking monster!
I don't even know how I got here!
What?
What the fuck is the treasure, Pete?
See?
Be a good person and you get rewarded.
Oh, is this the treasure room?
Oh!
No, that's the entrance.
Hey, there's no...
How do I get to my treasure room?
What the fuck?
Where's my...
Where's my fucking treasure, Pete?
Oh my god, I don't know how I got here.
How did I get here?
Okay.
Alright.
It's that door.
You remember which one is the door that...
Pete came...
Okay, there you go.
This is the door.
Yeah!
I got a bronze pin!
Let's go!
I got the coliseum...
Oh my god.
These two girls murdered her.
Now murder you all.
Okay, let's grab some more tickets.
Uh...
This way.
Off we go!
I'm pretty sure like, run dash is the fastest combo.
Let's grab tickets.
Tickets, please!
Oh?
Hey, what's down here?
Oh!
Secret!
Oh, nevermind.
It wasn't a...
Oh wait, no!
It was a secret!
Oh, money!
Okay, we don't need that money though.
And now we go back here.
Alright, before we go teleport into this movie...
I need to use the bathroom!
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back!
Uh...
Solid!
Power!
Neppers!
Min!
Butter!
Alan!
Zekra!
Bite!
Coyote!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright, let's get in.
Blue sky do!
We can do!
Yay!
Okay.
Go this way.
Alright, let's go this way.
Bye.
Wait, what?
There was film over there?
Oh wait, I'm heading there now.
I was like, oh no!
How did I miss that?
I was like, oh, I'm heading there.
Okay, nice.
No, that was my cha...
This is your childhood?
What?
You were like...
80?
Hey, this is the child, it is, like...
Okay.
Gotta go this way, I'm just saying, like, is this...
Isn't this short, like, 1930s or some shit?
Oh, wait, I have to grab this.
Oh, wait, what the fuck is over there?
Oh, no.
Oh, I knew there was a secret.
Alright, nice, we got extra content.
But what's over here?
Hi, Pete!
Yo, I actually just found out that...
Ow, shit!
Oh my god, I'm 1 HP, I wasn't paying attention.
I just found out that, uh...
He was actually, is actually a cat.
And that's why, you know, like...
Mickey Mouse and Pete the cat.
I didn't realize he was a cat.
Until now.
This is a game that made me realize he was a cat.
I don't know, I just see him as...
I never saw him as, like...
I don't know, I just never see him as, like, an actual animal.
An animal.
Wait, what does this do?
I knew it!
Oh, no!
I didn't know!
Yeah!
Cause they just call him Pete.
They never call him Pete the cat.
Just call him...
Little Pete.
Yeah, like, you can tell Goofy's a dog.
Because, like, you know, like, look at him.
But...
But, like...
Pete, as a cat, was not very, like...
What's over there?
Wasn't very, like...
Obvious?
In general?
Cause I never knew he was actually a cat.
What do you think he was?
He sort of looks like a dog, too.
Like, you know, like an angry, angry dog.
Why?
Yeah, I'm ready.
He looks...
He looks a lot like a dog, too.
Alright.
It's a small one after all.
Oh, you didn't tell...
This is the Wii portion of the game.
Like the...
The crosshair for this.
That's where I would point my Wii at.
My Wii mode.
Is he behind me?
Oh, there's...
Alright, let's go.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Reach the crosshair.
How do I reach it?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh!
I'll give you fingers!
Friendship!
Friend!
Be my...
Oh my god.
Be my friend!
Please!
Oh my god.
I don't know if he's gonna be my friend.
Be my friend!
I can fix you!
I'll
fix you!
I'll fix you!
I can't hear a bear's stare.
Wait a minute.
Wait!
He fucking...
Oh my god.
Is this like, time?
I talk too long?!
That's a thing?!
I didn't know you could take too long!
I just wanted to be friends!
Please, I'm recharging my friendship meter!
Please!
Friend B!
Please, please, please, please.
I didn't know.
I didn't know my friendship meters.
I'm trying so hard to be his friend, God, I swear to God.
Please, please, please!
Are we friends now?
Oh my God, we're friends now!
Hello!
Friend!
I'm afraid I was out of my head for a bit there.
Sorry!
Yay!
We're friends now!
Sorry for almost trying to kill you!
Just friend things!
Your pain can change based on how you deal with important characters in Wasteland.
Oh, yeah!
Alright.
Nice.
He's just trying to be a silly friend.
Alright, travel?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Sorry for trying to kill you earlier.
Hee hee!
Just...
Just a little joke.
You know?
Oh!
Oswald called you as best as you could.
He wanted those characters to be happy.
Characters that world stopped watching and stopped loving.
Rough traps, any extras, anyone characters left on the drawing board.
Most lived in Oswald's recreation.
He sets up shops, an ice cream pile there.
What?
It was home before.
Before what?
Before the thinner disaster.
Oh no!
That's when my life went out of Wasteland.
Who could have done such a thing?
Oh my god!
Oh god!
A terrible person did this!
That's when the blot arrived in his flunkies.
Thus is what's left of Oswald's creation, Mickey.
Welcome to Mean Street.
Mickey!
Gus!
A monster, no doubt!
We should jail that fucker!
Hello, Uncle Gus!
Good to see you, Marcus.
By any chance, have you seen Oswald lately?
Last time I saw him, he was headed towards the projector screens at the end of the street.
But those have been broken for a long time now.
If I can get that projector screen ready again.
If you can get me a pair of gears.
Horse can probably be found in the detective agency.
I know he has one.
He used to brag about his gear.
He's usually hanging around the city hall.
I'll be waiting outside a penny arcade.
Come see me when you have those gears.
Yeah, we must find the perpetrators who did such a heinous crime.
How dare they...
Poor sinner here.
Okay.
Who could do such a fucked up thing to these poor people?
Hello, guys.
I'm so sorry!
He's okay, he's fixed now.
Guys, it's okay.
He's fixed now.
He's fixed.
He's...
Guys, nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
He's...
He's okay.
Nothing happened.
What?
Guys, it's okay.
It's not...
Look at him.
Nothing happened.
Look.
He's happy.
He's...
Look at him.
He's so happy.
Nothing happened.
What happened?
He's so happy.
They're different versions from different stories.
Like me.
I thought these folks were forgotten.
I never forgot.
You, Big Pete, Bad Pete!
Big Bad Pete, Pete Pan, Small Pete, Petronic.
This place has got lots of me.
We got things done in Wasteland Sea.
So work with us and nobody will mess with you.
I'm Big Bad Pete, the one and only.
I'm the go-to guy around here.
And don't you forget it.
Nothing gets done if I ain't around.
And I hears about everything, including your running with Small Pete back in the world of Gremlins.
So here, have some e-tickets.
But don't think this means I decided to like you.
Oh nice, I got Small Pete.
Small Pete may be a real chowder head, but I'm glad you helped him.
Even though I know you're in need of a gear that I'm rumored to have.
Well, here's the deal on the gear.
Big Mouth Gilda is always bragging about fascists.
So, I set up a race for her.
Told her I'd give her a prize if she could beat it.
Seeing as how I didn't think she could.
Well anyways, she did.
But we never agreed on no prize.
So I gave her that worthless gear.
Ha!
Bottom line is, I don't got it no more.
The girl over by the firehouse station does.
So I can't help her even if I wanted to.
But maybe she can.
Otherwise, tough love.
Oh, oh, so I don't know.
Oh, that's nice.
Okay, but like what if I go...
He's right there.
It would be a shame if something happens to that man.
Give me a...
Guys, I'm not a criminal, guys.
I didn't do nothing.
Uh...
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's only so many little accidents that can happen.
But they already stopped being either little or accidents.
What did I do?
Hey there, I'm Gilda.
I'm a little bit adventurous like yourself.
I just got back from the Mickey Junk Mountain.
That scary place.
I was camping in the old collector's hut when Lotlin showed up.
Had a good old fast.
Oh, being up on that ledge was safe.
But I was wrong.
Left my prize climbing axe behind.
Oh well.
Maybe I'll come across another one soon.
But anyway...
Okay, so I need to find her lost axe.
Okay.
You want to try my time trial race?
I smashed Pete's gold time and he gave me this gear as a reward.
If you could beat my time, I could pass the gear along to you.
Follow the guardian and reach the checkered class flag before the clock runs up.
Yeah, sure.
Can't be that difficult.
Okay.
Let's get started.
Ready?
Three...
Two...
One...
Go!
Okay.
Okay...
Here...
I don't put up.
Okay.
Oh, the hard part is just I don't know where the race ends.
Okay, down.
Oh my god, there's more over here?
Oh my god, this is a big map.
Oh, there's more!
Oh, what?
Great job, Mickey!
As promised, here's the gear you wanted!
You want a gear from Gilda?
Now let's go to Horus at the detective agency to see about the gear he has!
Okay, so I need to find an axe for Gilda.
Let me paint this a little bit so I can hide my crimes.
Nothing bad happened!
I didn't do nothing!
Anyway, oh, these are like... Oh my god, okay, I'm missing 1, 2, 3, 4, so I completed two worlds already.
Oh.
Kiteam Museum should be funny, but this is kind of sad these days.
Nothing a little paint can cover up, right?
Mark, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, what a world, what a world.
What is this, though?
Oh my, is that who I think it is?
My goodness, it's you, Mickey Mouse!
Oh, that's me!
Oh, you didn't see nothing!
Hahaha!
How have you ended up here?
Alright, let's...
Where are you?
Welcome to my shop, Mickey!
Oh, there's the place where I can buy stuff!
Visited the home.
I arrived in Wonderland.
Wait, what?
Or, is this like...
All the stuff I didn't get?
Oh!
Oh my god, they have the pin...
Oh my god, they have the fucking pins.
They brought the pin collecting here, too.
They actually brought the pin collecting here.
Oh, I could get rid of it, okay.
We're not getting rid of that.
We're not bad people, guys.
Welcome to the Horse Caller Investigation, can I?
Oh my!
Mickey, do you remember me?
Horse, Horse Caller?
I was in the Fire Fighters!
The Barnyard Broadcast!
The Band!
Oh, yeah!
That one!
I love...
I like that one.
The band concert one.
Don't remember, huh?
That's alright.
Nobody else did.
Taiwan up here.
Same as everyone else.
No, Horace!
I remember you!
Here in the wasteland, I'm...
an ace detective.
At least, I like the bee.
Haven't solved the case in years, but you need an investigator?
I'm your guy.
Business is down these days.
I'm sure it will pick up any time now.
I'm one of yours that is used to power up the projector screen machine to Oz Town.
I can give it to you, but I need you to do something for me first.
Such a downer.
Whatever his name is.
Casey the Emporium ordered a book from you a while ago, but never returned it.
Can you go see if he still has it?
Bring it back to me, and...
I'll give you the gear.
Alright.
Recover the Horace book.
Okay, we can do that.
It's like over here.
Alright.
I understand that you're looking for horrors this book?
Well, that's a problem.
I finished reading it a while ago, and lent it to Pauline, the ice cream pot owner.
His shop is just down the street from here.
You should go ask him about it.
Okay, we gotta go ask Pauline now.
Oh my god.
This is a fetch quest right now.
So many of these, like...
Like, default characters here.
Oh, this is another Casey.
Well, he had the muscle flexed him.
Folks around here will get out of the way.
No, don't do it.
Don't...
Don't do it.
I didn't do it.
I didn't listen to my thoughts.
Hey there.
My name is Pauline.
And I'm the owner of the ice cream parlor.
Don't listen to the voices.
Ice cream is hard to come by these days.
So sometimes I don't have much variety.
Business has been slow.
But reading keeps me entertained when there's no customers.
That's why I also sell enhancements and filters for your photo mode nowadays.
You're looking for the book that Casey lent me?
I wasn't quite finished with it yet.
But I suppose you can have it anyway.
Stop by again.
Okay, so what are the filters?
A delicious high...
Oh, I want an ice cream.
I'll buy this ice cream just because I can.
What does it do?
I have one ice cream.
Okay.
So what does this one ice cream do?
Let's put this ice cream back.
Oh, okay.
Oh,
okay, so it's...
got your book.
Great!
You recovered my book.
How to be a detective.
Now I'm almost ready to reopen my agency.
Hopefully, things go better for me this time.
That's why I was here as a gear unit.
Don't be too hard on Oswald.
He really does try.
Yay, we got, guys.
We got more guys.
Nah, both gears, Mickey.
Let's hurry back to the Gremlin Marcus.
Okay, guys.
Did I... Good ending, right?
Okay.
I'm still getting the good ending, right, guys?
It's still happening, right?
Only, sure.
I haven't snored with since.
Oh, it felt like forever.
You should talk to Pete and Horace.
Yeah.
Oh, okay, guys.
Guys, look at that.
No consequences, guys.
No consequences.
At all.
Unfortunately.
Yay!
We can still get the good ending, guys.
Yippee.
Okay, so I assume he's like... Okay, he's over there.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
I can still be a hero.
I'm still a hero.
I'll be a Mickey Mouse.
Now I've seen it all!
Oh, there he is.
You covered both the gears?
Fantastic!
There's only one more thing yet to do to get this thing running.
You see, when a machine broke, its energy was scattered around the park in the form of Powers Park.
Famous people have picked him up, and some have yet to be found.
We will need one of them to start up the Oztown projector screen.
I'm pretty sure I saw one on display at the museum.
You should go have a look.
I saw that.
Try visiting with Casey the Emporium.
I think I saw him with one earlier.
Okay, oh my god.
Go back.
Come one, come all.
Come see our latest cartoon escape bids.
Hey, you're an adventurous type.
We always need more cartoons here.
If you haven't found anything during travel, bring them up for a reward.
You can see the stars here.
Sometimes we have famous patrons, including you, of course.
Feel free to step inside and play through these exciting moments again.
Oh, this is when I got the film reel.
Oh, nice.
Here.
Oh, I get paid.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Flashbang!
I was not expecting that.
Holy shit.
I was not expecting that flashbang.
What's this?
Oh, hey.
Steamboat Willie.
Yes.
Oh!
Is this back for the 2D stuff?
Steamboat Willie?
Oh, it's me replaying this.
Wait.
How do I...
I wanna leave.
Oh my god.
To finish.
Okay.
I thought I was watching the movie.
But that's fine.
I can fast-track this.
What's...
Oh my God!
Losing people....
Alright.
Yeah.
I just wanna know what that was.
I thought I was watching a movie!
I was like, oh my god, I get to watch Team Bowie!
But it was just to, like...
Oh, yeah, it was just to, like, play... replay the 2D portions.
Okay, now I know what this is.
Okay, so...
There's one, two, three, four, five, six more worlds left.
Okay, wow.
Oh, my God.
Alright.
The way he said it, it seemed like I had to just watch it there now.
Okay, let's go...
Get our...
Let's go get this power spark.
Give me the power spark!
Do you have one new exhibit?
See it glowing?
What?
You need that crazy glowing orb in the display case?
I'll let you have a power spark if you can find something more interesting to replace it.
All sorts of things get left behind at the cinema.
You should talk...
God damn it!
God fucking damn it!
Okay.
Alright, let's ask him for the other one.
Why don't you guys ask each other?
It's, like, five steps away!
I locked myself out of my back room again.
I think I dropped my key near Polly's ice cream parlor.
The key must be somewhere around the front of the store.
Could you go look around for me?
Oh, my...
Guys.
It's literally...
10 steps.
You could have got your key 10 steps ago.
Okay, I had to do that to find the key.
Where the fuck is the key?
This is...
Oh, it's right here.
Wait, is that...
No, that's just...
No.
How do I get up there?
You said he left it...
Oh, there's Polly now?
No?
Polly, where the fuck is this key?
He said he left it at Polly's ice cream shop.
Is it here?
No?
Oh!
I'm so dumb.
Okay.
I'll talk to...
him for the...
I have a cut list that was left here by Captain Hook himself.
You're looking for something in the museum?
Yeah.
I guess Hook's cut list would be a good exhibit.
Since you already brought some film strips to me, I'll let you have this for free.
Okay, nice.
All right.
Now...
That should be almost everything.
I'm so smart.
Okay, and then we'll grab this one from here.
Find my back room key!
I'll give you something from inside as a reward!
Hopefully the power spark is okay with you.
All right, and then we give...
It to her.
Over here.
All right.
Look at this cut list.
It's quite the specimen.
I'll gladly trade you the power spark for this fine piece.
Thanks, Mickey.
Remember to stop by anytime.
Okay, nice.
All right.
Now we have everything.
Okay, and then we can get Oztown back.
You retrieved the power spark.
Now I can get the projector screen to Oztown working.
Now let's see what's happening to this device.
Fiddle here.
Adjust that.
Voila!
A projector screen to Oztown is working perfectly.
Oh, you're gone.
I'll try tinkering with the other projector screen.
Good luck, Mickey.
And take these e-tickets to help you on your adventure.
Nice.
What do I do with these e-tickets?
I get so many e-tickets for that.
I don't know what to do.
I mean, it's just like the audit parks.
Dad?
Um, with a few changes, of course.
Oswald?
He's like...
Brother?
He's like, I have a...
That's when Mickey found out he has a...
He has a long forgotten brother.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki's homelander moment.
Oh my god.
There's gonna be a space level.
What's this level?
I assume this is like...
Me being tiny.
And then there's the haunted house level.
And there's a tiki level.
Which one is he?
Oh.
Oh, this is the one to go.
I've always wanted a brother.
You want to travel to Oztown?
Yes!
Take me to Oztown.
Which one is this?
Oh!
Oh my god, I can't believe Super Mario copied it.
I'm joking, guys.
Well, no shame in Super Mario for copying it.
Please.
Wait, does that hurt me?
No, it doesn't.
Oh my god!
No, he doesn't hurt me, though.
Oh my god, she's dancing!
Whoa!
Oh my god, I killed her.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I don't know this episode.
Actually.
This episode's not that familiar to me.
We all saw...
No, no, no.
Nothing happened.
Nothing happened between me and her.
I'm bum bum bum bum bum.
Oh, there's a film over there!
Do I get over there?
Yeah, I can.
Oh, shit.
That's why I can tank it hit.
Wow.
I don't know what to expect.
I don't know.
I thought... I thought it was friendly.
Wait, what?
What's the point of going down here?
There's nothing down here.
Yeah, I don't remember.
I don't think I've seen this episode.
Oh, I didn't get any film.
Oh, whatever.
Wait, actually?
I think it's because I didn't... Oh, I have to go all the way there.
Friendly fire.
I thought it was friendly fire!
Oh, I knew it!
I knew it!
I knew I'm so smart.
Through that mirror.
Yeah, go back to Oz Town.
That's like I saw a hole.
And when there's a hole, there's always a goal.
Hello!
Hey, it's so friendly!
Welcome to Oz Town!
It doesn't look too bad.
It looks like Donald's tugboat sank since I was last here.
Donald?
I've always liked that Oswald statue.
That fellow standing from the gag factor is named Moody.
He's Moody.
Donald?
Donald's here?
Donald, what are you doing here?
Everybody loves you!
Clarabelle?
No!
Land 6 Mickey Mouse?
It's Clarabelle!
Why, you must remember me!
Yeah, Clarabelle isn't a forgotten character.
Look, look, look!
I was in Mickey's melodramar.
And Mickey's polo team.
I dined with the stars.
Orphan's benefit both the original and...
Yeah, she's not forgotten.
She's...
She's Goofy's girlfriend!
Before, like, they gave him away.
I'll just get back to my garden.
With all the commotion.
It's the only thing that makes me happy.
Yeah.
She was in House and Mouse, too.
So you're going after Oswald, are you?
That sounds dangerous.
No, she...
At one point, they made her Goofy's girlfriend, too.
And then, like...
Like...
Like, she would, like, chase after Goofy and stuff.
And then they retconned that and gave Goofy a dead wife.
So you're going after Oswald?
That sounds dangerous.
If you're going to Mickey Junk Mountain, you'll need to fix that bridge.
There was a gremlin happening around here.
But it's been missing a while.
Oh, but before I forget, something has been making noise over near the gag factory.
Can you go see what it is?
It sounds like something might be calling for help.
I'll go check it out myself.
But, well...
You know.
You know what?
Don't do it.
I didn't do it.
I did it.
I got it.
I didn't do it.
Wait...
Goofy?
That's Goofy.
I mean...
Sort of.
It's an animatronic, Goofy.
Oswald built him with the mad doctor's help.
Oswald wanted a friend like your pal.
Gosh.
Hello, Mickey.
Where's the rest of him?
What happened to you, Goofy?
Oh, gosh.
Well, I was doing some work in Tomorrow City.
And the mad doctor went at some of his own friends tear me in pieces.
And now my parts are scattered all over.
No account you had to put me together again, Mickey.
Oh, gosh.
Hey, Mickey.
Do you think you could help me up?
The mad doctor scattered all my body parts around Tomorrow City.
If you were going by there, could you get them put me back together?
Okay.
My Five Nights at Freddy's.
So close.
It's right there.
Oh, shit.
I wonder if I paint their house back.
Will I be able to go into their house?
Don't keep food.
Oh, wait.
Oz one copied my house?
That's fucking creepy, buddy.
Amelia, at your service, Mickey.
Welcome to Oz's house.
Your house here is, you know...
And I saw something bright and glowing in the room.
I hope it's not trouble.
That's fucking creepy, bro.
Make your...
Bro, make your own house.
Hello?
Mickey Mouse?
Welcome to the Wasteland Bridge of your house.
That's so creepy.
Bro, like, he's not even creative.
Bro.
Not even fucking creative enough to make his own house.
There's, like, something shiny?
What does he mean?
This?
He said there was something shiny on my roof, but I don't see it.
What?
Where was it?
He was like, there's something shiny here.
I'm, like, so confused.
Let's paint this house back.
Oh, shit!
Not fully painted back.
Wait, what?
It's fully painted.
Oh, never mind.
Can I go in now?
Stupid house.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
What is it?
I'm double-checking?
Yeah, I fully fucking fixed this house.
It's like, doing a half...
What do you mean?
They said...
She said there was something shiny on the roof.
Where is it?
I don't see no shine.
What?
The corners.
What am I doing?
Power flush simulating?
I did the corners!
Get out the roofs.
Oh, my God.
This house is fixed.
I fixed everything!
I give up.
You keep this stupid ass house.
How do I...
I can't jump on that roof.
It won't let me.
Oh, see?
I can't get on top of it.
Oh, this one?
What the fuck do I fix this house?
Oh!
I knew that.
I knew that, guys.
Wait.
No, what?
That doesn't make sense.
Doesn't make sense.
That's it.
I'm destroying this house.
That's fucking it.
I'm angry.
That's it.
Fuck your house, Oswald!
That's right!
Try to copy my house!
That's fucking right!
Fuck your house!
Oh, wait.
There it is.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Evil!
That's right.
You don't... you don't steal my house!
I'll...
Erase your house, Oswald.
That's goddamn right!
I'll brace everything you love!
The work of a villain, I see.
Sayonara!
Folks keep trying to visit the Gag Factory, only to find out it's been out of...
And I get rewarded!
It's the bright colors that fool them.
Send out as much of it as you can, and I'll make it worth your while.
Wait, what?
He wants me to send out...
When I show up, you show up, and also, I knew I mean good things.
Do you even know...
That you repaired my house for me?
Now I don't have to hang out in the safe for shelter all day.
Speaking of the safe, you wanna know the combination?
Something in there complains all the time.
I'm kinda tired of it.
Here's the combination.
Wait, how do I fucking get that?
Okay.
Oh.
Go to your house.
Go to your fucking house.
Why aren't you...
Go to your house!
I fixed your house!
Don't...
Don't do it!
But I fixed it!
Oh...
I almost killed him!
Oh, I did it.
I'm a hero.
I was about to risk it all.
What a good likeness.
Thank you for rescuing me.
I owe you one.
Head to the Mickey Chunk Mountain?
I can help.
Boy, I need my wrench.
When I tinkered that telephone in your house, it tricked me into the safe.
I'm sure he has my wrench.
So you don't need to go and get it back from him.
Let me know when you have it.
Why does he want me to...
Should I actually thin it out?
I don't know.
Oh, he moved.
See guys?
He moved.
Alright.
It's not my house.
It's Oswald.
Okay, copying my shit.
P. Scott wants his wrench back?
No way!
Look, if he gets his wrench back, he's going to disassemble me.
Dissemble!
He's so mad that I'm locked up in that safe.
Really, though.
He had it coming.
Anyway, I'll tell you you need the wrench, so I'll tell you what...
I can tell you you need the wrench, so I'll tell you what you need.
If you help me restore my signal to the Main Street, I'll give you the wrench.
There are three more power boxes like this one around Oswald's town.
Enabling them will allow me to reach people in Main Street.
Okay.
That's fine.
He's not even a gremlin.
I respect that it's your house, but you let me get in there, I'll get my wrench back.
Can I go in and get my wrench?
Okay, no.
Calm down.
I'll fix it.
I can fix it.
Okay, where the fuck is the power thing?
Wait.
Where the fuck is it?
He said there's three around here.
I know you wanna beat him up, but we can fix this.
What?
We don't need to fix the house.
This is already activated, see?
He said there's three more here.
I don't see it.
Where the fuck is the three other powers?
He doesn't deserve this.
Also does not deserve it.
You know it.
He's gonna be really fixed.
Fix.
Okay, that should be fully fixed, right?
There we go.
They're happy I fixed the stupid house.
Goddamn copycat.
Copycat.
Oh my god.
There was no point in fixing it.
There was no point.
Where is it?
Okay, I feel like I can hear... the thing too.
Oh my god, what the fu... Okay, that was random.
I literally did not think that was... I... Oh.
I'm a genius.
Where is it?
Okay, maybe... I'll... get rid of the color here.
He said that... he doesn't like that the gag shot...
had color.
Oh hey, what's this?
Alright.
Uh, hold on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, where is the guy?
What the fu... I... ruined your gag factory!
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god.
How much more do you want me to thin out?
What's this?
Thin enough?
Yeah, I'm doing Power Wash Simulator.
Yeah.
It's just Power Wash Simulator with extra steps.
Yeah, let's have... oh my god, it's over here.
OH MY GOD!
Okay, there's one.
Two more to go.
Let's get rid of this real fast.
Oh nice!
A power spark!
That's actually what we needed.
Okay, is that enough for it?
Who wanted this here?
Now that place won't have much... so much attention now.
Have a power spark.
Also...
Oh Ducky, good to see you good.
I love all the things you've been doing.
Keep at it like that.
And wish you the best of the past.
Thank you!
Thank you super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we got two.
Oh, we got... we need two more.
What the fu... is the other two?
I feel it!
Oh hey, nice.
What?
Oh!
One more to go...
Oh my god, they're like hidden like that?
Oh my god, I should have just let him beat up the telephone.
I...
God fucking...
I should have just let him beat up the telephone.
He deserves it.
This is too much work.
Where's the last one though?
That's the thing.
Where is the last one?
I'm trying to find it.
Cause that's the one where I found earlier.
Like behind that wall?
Where the fuck is the last one?
Huh.
I don't see it.
The floor?
Is it near the floor?
Not here.
I swear to god, if I don't find it...
This guy's gotta beat up a telephone.
I swear...
If I don't find it...
I'm letting him in there.
Letting him fucking...
Beat up that fucking telephone.
Almost said it's like in the grass.
I'm mad.
It's just a power pop.
The things I do for less violence.
Where the fuck am I...
Okay guys.
Guys.
I need help.
SOS.
Where is it?
On the grass?
Okay.
I'll ruin her stupid...
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
No wonder people would just let him beat up the fucking stupid ass.
That is actually...
Oh my god.
That is...
How was I supposed to figure that out?
How...
Who the fuck lived here?
Who lived here?
There's like a secret hidden bunker.
Someone actually slept here.
Yeah.
This is like the harder version.
I could have just looked away.
I could have let him in that house.
Looked away.
Power boxes are restored.
I could not reach even further than Mean Street.
That should keep me busy for a while.
Thanks.
Here's the wrench I promised.
Can you do one more thing with me?
I'm trying to reach a phone out.
In Mickey Junk Mountain.
You dial 76 on one of the phones out here?
It should help me find a connection again.
I will work for you when you get back.
Okay.
Alright.
Use your stupid ass wrench.
Now I have a wrench so I can fix this bridge.
Alright.
Here you go.
Okay, let him go.
He's doing it.
Yeah!
Good luck on Mickey Junk Mountain, Mickey.
Okay, let's go.
I fucking did it.
I didn't destroy too much.
Alright.
Mickey Steamroller.
Guess I'm ready.
Blue Skat Bee.
Go!
Who'sogn tinting, so can you!
Yay!
Murder!
Let's go!
Technically, it's not me committing the murder.
It's this train.
It's not my fault.
Yay!
Property damage!
Let's go!
Fuck this city!
We built this city.
Oh my god.
That way.
Oh hey, money.
Oh fuck!
Okay, that scared me actually.
I can grab the money from here.
Yay!
Wait.
Okay, we don't need that one dollar.
That's like one dollar.
Oh my god!
Okay, I did not expect that to happen.
Oh no.
Okay guys, that's fine.
That's like two dollars.
We don't need that.
Oh wait, I can just double jump that.
What the fuck?
I absolutely did not need that.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, are you serious?
No.
No, you fucker.
No!
How was I supposed to know there was a film there?
Until I actually there?
How was I...
Oh, I guess we're never doing that...
Wait, unless...
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
There's always a secret there.
Alright, go back to Mickey Junk Mountain.
Oh my god, look at all the junk.
There.
I like the little illustrations in the loading screen.
It's really cute.
There's the... What the fuck?
There's a mountain we have to... Is this capitalism?
There's a mountain we have to climb.
Also it's century us all the way up to the top.
It won't be easy to reach him.
You see... You see he doesn't really want visitors.
Oh, funny children.
Wonderful.
Wait, he has children?
Funny children but they look cute.
But don't get too many around you.
Or they become significantly less cute.
And when they see a spatter, they get incredibly uncute.
From the spatter's perspective anyway.
I vaguely recall that old crane being powered by some sort of electrical system.
It appears to be an operator on duty.
We could ask him for more information.
Okay, Sika, Oswald.
Oh, Huey, Dewey, and Louie!
Alright.
Let's go...
This way.
Oh my god, why aren't your cameras here?
Oh my god, who's fucking watching me right now?
Alright, let's go this way.
Friend?
Friend.
Wait.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god, they fucking picked me up!
Oh my god, what is wrong with you?
Fan!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Fan!
Fan bunnies!
Ah!
Get me outta here!
We need to use...
Are you gonna get up to the mountain?
Sure, if it worked.
Here, man.
Notice the bunny children?
They dislike splatters.
Which...
How does it go?
The enemy of my enemy is my friend.
Anyway, there should be some TVs nearby.
Now, power this piece of junk.
Paint them to activate.
They'll be able to clear that way.
Oh my god.
Get them away.
They're tall.
Oh my god.
Oswald, control your children!
Oswald!
Control your kids!
Oh my god, time has slowed.
I don't know where to go.
I slowed the time, but where do I go?
Okay.
Jesus, this is so dystopian.
Wait, what?
Why can't...
Oh!
That's a thinner!
Okay.
Oswald is a bad father!
Okay, where the fuck do I go?
Oh my god, they're all...
Look at him.
They're just...
Waiting for me.
Look at him.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, friend!
Oh my god, don't let him pick me up.
Don't let him touch me.
Get them away from me.
Did he just eat him?
Why is he so big?
Oh!
Alright, we just gotta...
We gotta make sure we're not next to that.
Friend.
Oh!
Okay, we gotta get him in here.
That's...
I was like wondering.
Why is he so big?
He's so much bigger.
I was free at...
The Gremlin.
Hello?
Well Mickey, now that I'm free, I can use my special gift in your service.
My original training was in...
Crane repair.
I'll fix this one in a jiffy.
Which crane is this one?
Oh, nice!
You did it!
Watch this!
What is he doing?
Oh!
Be warned.
Not many have returned.
Oh no.
Don't worry.
I'm Mickey Mouse.
I'm the main character.
Nothing bad will happen to the main character.
Okay, let's go this way.
And then...
Oh yay!
Money!
Bee!
Okay.
Oh...
Just gotta make sure everything is good.
What is like over there?
Oh my god!
Get away from me!
Get away from me kids!
Get away!
Don't touch me!
I wanna go there!
But I don't know if I can.
You guys see that, right?
There's something over here.
Oh my god.
They're just waiting for me.
These fucking bricks.
Oh, thank god.
How do I get over there?
Oh, maybe from here?
Oh, it's from here.
Okay.
I can make it.
Okay, that's fine.
Get away, children.
Get away, child!
Don't touch me!
I forgot what happened.
Nothing bad has happened, guys.
Nothing bad happened.
Nothing bad.
Friend.
Friendship.
No, no, no.
Guys.
What's over here?
Oh, shit!
Guys, what was the number?
Guys, guys!
What was the number?
I...
726?
I didn't remember!
What was...
What was the number?
726, right?
Okay.
7...
2...
6.
Hello, hello?
My connection to Mickey Junk Mountain is restored again.
Mickey.
Mickey, make sure to come back to the Nasdawn for a reward.
Okay, I did it.
Friendship.
Oh, look!
See?
They're watching TV!
Peak friendship right there, guys.
Oh, my God.
They're all waiting for me.
They're all...
They're all waiting.
I see them right now.
The children yearn for the hugs.
Oh, my God.
I should've been giving the TV right here.
Get away!
Watch your TV!
Oh, my God.
The children has been satisfied.
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
They started watching TV.
Right.
Get up there again.
Let's this way.
It's okay.
They've been satisfied.
They're watching TV now.
They can't hurt me no more.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
All right.
Oh!
Is this a...
Beanstalk?
I didn't see the film for this.
What?
I didn't see the title of this one.
Oh, there's the film.
No!
Aw!
End.
Uh, Darkblade!
Did you have a super chat?
Did you think?
Yeah.
Epic battle.
We've all been waiting for.
Doki bird versus iPad kid colorized.
Oh, no.
It's not.
It's something to do with the...
The goats.
Alpine climbers.
I feel like I've seen an episode of this, but...
I'm not sure.
It is a little familiar.
I don't think I can beat him up.
I think he'll beat me up before.
Oh, no!
I can use it as a platform.
Nice.
It's just an egg.
The fuck?
Okay, I think that guy is mad at me.
Oh, no.
I can use him as a platform.
Nice.
Okay.
This is...
Can I crack it?
No.
Okay.
Guys, it's not a...
I'm not doing an evil thing, but I do.
I'm just curious if I can crack it, you know?
Like, it's just curiosity.
Okay, this way.
Not the egg.
Maybe...
I thought it would be like a little Easter egg, you know?
You get it?
Aha!
Like a little Easter egg.
Okay.
I'm ready to enter the pile.
Alright, let me get in.
This is Hopper.
The simplest form of Beetleworks.
What the fuck?
Then I can remove it, but it does no damage.
You have to clobber them up close.
Oh, I can kill.
I can murder now.
Guys, they're not fixable, so it's fine.
Murder is okay.
You can't fix them.
Here we go.
That's right.
You're not fixable.
Death is all you deserve.
Oh dear, most of them broke through.
That's right.
Boom!
I know you're not fixable.
You're...
You're beyond redeemable.
Murder is okay.
Murder is okay when you're beyond redeemable.
Okay, I just gotta make sure I'm not missing anything.
Alright, let's go this way.
Alright, up we go.
Finally!
Finally I can do what I was born to do.
My intrusive thoughts can finally win.
What's this?
What?
Oh.
Okay, that's how you stop it.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Alright.
That's a spladoosh.
They tend to sleep, and that's a good thing.
When they're awake, they're very excitable, and they later explode.
And believe me, you'd agitate them.
Luckily, they can't move at all.
Friend.
Yeah!
You can just make them friend.
See?
Friend.
Oh, see?
Oh, when they're friends, they'll sleep forever.
Yeah, why self when... Exactly!
Okay, can you feel like...
I don't know.
Okay, here we go.
Come to a friend, and they'll sleep forever.
Wait, what?
Why isn't it working?
Oh, I have to put thinner in there.
Right?
If I have to?
No.
I already put thinner.
Wait, what?
Oh, I opened the path!
Oh!
Okay, I was like so confused.
Arv is still...
...running.
Okay.
Oh, this is easy.
I'll just dash through it.
Alright.
So easy.
Am I missing anything?
Is there anything above me?
Oh, wait, what?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh!
Would that...
That would be the danger...
Oh!
If I decide...
This is the easy path.
And then like...
If I decide to be a bad person...
They would make me parkour!
Oh!
I see.
Yeah, cause I was like wondering like...
Wait, this is so easy.
Yeah, I got the...
Cause like look at the green stuff.
This has to be the easy part.
Right?
Cause like...
What's the green stuff over there?
Being evil is...
Why be evil when I can just...
I can just do this the easy way.
Crime never pays.
Ow.
Oh my...
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
I was like...
Why would there be the green stuff?
Yeah, I know.
I was like...
Excuse me?
Like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
My tickets.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Do that.
Okay, we made it.
Yeah, this is such an easy parkour.
What's this?
That looks the way out.
RUN!
Pressure beam!
There we go.
You shall become a dragoon.
Wait, why is there another call?
Wait.
Nine.
One.
Is that a wrong number on the phone?
Wait.
Nine.
One.
Oh shit.
Wait, try one, one.
One.
Two.
Aw.
No call.
I got them.
What if, like, I do that and the game fucking deletes inside?
Disney lawyers will get me.
Oh, there's something over here.
I like how the melee is, like, an extra jump.
I like that mechanic.
Can I make that?
No, I have to actually do this.
There.
Alright, we gotta do this one.
Can I make this?
Yeah, I can.
Yeah.
Burn.
Wait a minute.
Wait, my brush.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh fuck, I forgot.
Your doctor's a bullet.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Please keep beating my...
Oh my god!
We all saw it.
He jumped.
He jumped, guys.
We all saw it.
What?
That was not my fault.
We couldn't stop him.
We tried.
The casualty of war.
He was a good man.
But he had to fight his own inner demons.
We all saw it.
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait, we go this way.
I got it.
They're alive with this.
All right.
I'm ready to climb the mountains.
Okay, why did you push him?
What do you mean?
He knew.
We all saw what happened.
Oh, wait.
I remember this dog.
From that move...
From the episode.
I remember...
I know that dog.
Okay.
Let's get this.
All right.
Let's grab this.
And then...
No!
Stupid...
Oh!
Stupid bird.
Don't make me look bad.
Booga booga booga booga.
All right.
We just have to wait.
I can be patient.
I should survive that.
I'm a parkour queen!
Okay.
Grab this.
Grab the money.
And then...
Grab the film.
Yay!
Oh, shit!
I'm okay.
Just a little accident.
Yes.
All right.
Oh.
Excuse us.
We need to go in and see Oswald.
Sorry.
That door is out of commission.
No power, you see.
Even it worked.
And I can't open that door.
It's not as bald things are about.
Get rid of them and I'll open the door.
Or you can try powering it yourself.
I like this hut where Gilda left your axe.
Is up on that ledge.
How do we reach it?
All right.
We gotta send the mountains.
Knock, knock.
Wait, what?
Not fully?
Oh!
There's a fucking vent!
Okay, I was gonna say like...
What the fuck is going on?
There's like a...
I didn't see the little droplet.
Okay.
Just...
Just make sure that is friendly first before we do anything.
Okay.
All right.
I'm trying my best.
Wait, what?
He just TP's.
What the fuck just happened?
He just TP'd out of there.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Okay, let's get rid of him first.
And then...
Get rid of him.
Oh my god.
I can unfriend them.
I didn't know that.
It can be like not friends anymore if I hit them.
That's right.
I unfriended you.
Okay.
Wait.
Can I like complete this puzzle?
How about I complete this puzzle?
Okay.
And then...
Let's grab this guy.
I unfriended her.
Thanks for dealing them all.
I'll store power to the gates.
Give my regards to our leader Oswald when you see him.
Okay, so that is the path.
I need to grab the...
Goddamn...
Axe though.
That's here.
Oh, I knew it.
I was like...
That seems so weird.
I knew there was something there.
Yeah!
Oh!
Gold pin!
Grab that here.
Do I...
That?
Like...
Okay.
That's it?
I was like, ooh, a little game?
First try.
How do I get...
How do I get up there?
Hmm...
Grab this.
Okay.
That activates that.
Look at all my new friends I made.
Oh.
Okay, and then...
Oh my god, okay.
We still made it.
That's good.
Alright.
That should get rid of the thinner here.
I'm balling right now.
Truly am.
Okay, there's nothing behind me.
Oh, hey!
There's an NES!
What is this?
A magical quest.
Oh, this should be...
Where I can grab the thing.
Uh...
He's not thinner.
Oh!
Whoa!
No!
Okay.
Still made it.
We still made it.
Nice.
Oh!
Nice!
We did it!
We have our little...
Pickaxe.
Our gildalas.
Nice.
There was like, something over here.
Is it worth doing...
This one?
Is it worth doing the one over here?
Like, what do I get out of that?
I'm like, wondering...
What do I get out of doing this one?
Yeah, but like...
This is me turning the power on myself.
So it's like...
I don't have to do that.
I already turned it on.
I guess it's like, the challenge one?
Is this like, where I want to challenge myself?
Satisfaction?
Because I'm like...
This one was so easy.
I just like, painted everything.
But...
There's more parkour up here.
The satisfaction of a job?
Well done.
Because I'm like...
I praise.
Alright.
If I...
If I parkour...
I...
You know what?
I want a super chat.
If I...
Get all the way up there...
That's my praise.
I'll do it.
That was so easy.
This...
This is so easy.
Watch this.
I fucking am gaming.
Get out of here.
When?
Wait, but like...
Where am I...
Oh my god, it's this.
I was like, so confused.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I'll...
Do that.
And then...
Yeah, the door is open now.
So you don't need...
But we can if you...
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
That's exactly what I'm saying!
I was like, what do I get out of doing this?
The other one was so much more easier.
It's literally the satisfaction.
It's just a game.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh, I...
I'm like, I was so confused what that was.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
What the fuck is this TV doing here?
Is that it?
I did it!
Wait, that's it?!
I just turned on the TV?!
Okay, I did it, guys.
I did it.
That was it.
That was actually it.
Where's my super chat?
I got cracked.
Where is it?
I can't do anything near the TV.
What the fuck?
What's supposed to be here?
How do I get down?
Oh my god.
To walk all the way down?
Oh my...
The hardest part is getting down.
Boom!
Thank you for...
Thank you for the super...
Oh my god.
Wait, the hardest part is getting down.
Thank you for the super...
Congrats, I guess.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, I guess you did it.
How nice, you like painted it all for me.
I totally did it.
Like, why the fuck, why did they...
T-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats.
Paturasi, thank you.
Yeah, where's my golden star?
Where's my golden star?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey now, this is a kid-friendly game, Missy.
No swearing allowed.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, we're here.
Oh, it's like all the like, old merch and stuff they used to do.
That shit is so creepy though.
I remember seeing the concept bar for like, some of the Mickey...
Um...
Merch, like, in this game.
And it's so fucking dark.
I was with a lucky rabbit.
He was an actor.
Oh boy, he was an actor?
Charlie Troubles?
Oh, what a night.
Oswald was lost.
It was in lots of old films.
He was the first of us to become a star.
And the first of us to be forgotten.
Forgotten?
Why, what happened?
You happened.
Oh boy, me?
It seems pretty popular down here.
Of course, Oswald runs this place.
Or at least, he did.
Before the Sinner Disaster.
Sinner Disaster?
Wait, what?
He fell off.
He peeked and fell off, guys.
Star, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One more swear joke.
And you're out of the Mickey Mouse.
No!
M-I-C-K-E-Y M-O-U-S-E Mickey Mouse Donald Duck Mickey Mouse Donald Duck Pa-dum, pa-dum, pa-dum, pa-dum, pa-dum, pa-dum Oh, oh, oh Please, sir.
Don't kick me out!
Please, sir.
Don't kick me out of the Mickey Mouse club!
I bet I'm good mouse!
Solid thing of the super chat, think you think?
Yeah.
Come on.
Get no cameras.
No cameras allowed.
Looks like he's the one to talk around here.
Hello?
Whoa, look at all these cards.
Here we are.
Alright.
Oh, it's you.
You're not getting in to see him.
Not unless you pass the sum test.
Putting a fiver in this weird jar for you.
Curse, thank you for the super chat that you think you.
Go through the first projector stream on the left.
Prepare to have your ticket punched.
The three challenges.
Okay.
Ready for the first challenge?
Yeah, I am.
Ah, Mickey Mouse!
I like how it's the Oswald episode.
It says, presented by Mickey Mouse.
That's fucked up.
Santino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I only got my first super chat set.
Good job, Doki.
Yay!
I got my gold star.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yippee!
My gold star!
Whoa, it's Extendo.
Don't worry.
I got it.
I got that stupid cow out of here.
Extend your...
Extend your neck!
Okay.
Alright, we gotta go up.
Actually, do we go up?
Oh wait, yeah, we do.
That's where the film is.
The trolley troubles.
Go, go Gadget Mickey!
Eh?
What's this do?
I don't know what that did.
This is not really much of a challenge.
To be fair.
Yay!
Wait, what's over there?
Oh, I knew it.
I was like, there's a hole there.
I made it!
I suppose that could've been fluke.
Better be on the right caliber.
You're gonna make it through this one.
Alright.
Which one's this one?
Oh.
Presented by Mickey Mouse.
The Greek guns!
Yeah, I'm ready.
Congrats on passing a trial for kids.
Hey, I'm a kid at heart!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh yeah.
I forgot about that.
Oh yeah, that's all this one.
Just see.
Why is there...
I forgot like, back then like, uh, we had like, shorts based off the war and shit.
I forgot that was a thing.
That was a thing.
Oh my god, that's a tank!
It was like back then, to recruit for like the World War II, like, they made Walt Disney make like propaganda films and shit.
Oh my god, that's it.
Bro, that's hardcore.
Yeah.
Give him back!
Give Mickey his gun back!
Okay, nice, we got this.
Never forget what Goofy did.
Houston, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
He's like, well, they're like, Walt Disney, we need propaganda films.
And Walt Disney's like, okay.
I can't come up with any witty puns for this one.
Just jump through the projector screen, okay?
Mickey did things, awful things in the war.
Gosh, Mickey, we gotta tell everyone.
I know what you did in Vietnam, Mickey.
Oh, Goofy, why couldn't you just look away?
Don't remind W on the, oh my, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I totally just, that animation still lives red-free in my head.
The dors, Mickey, this dors here can end the war.
I'm sorry.
It's actually, it's so good.
Guys, you did that animation.
It will always live red-free in my head.
There has to be something here.
Kingdom Hearts gets wild!
Whoa!
Eh.
I got extra money.
Where am I?
Oh, wait, what?
I could fin- wait, then what's over to my right, or left?
I'm just gonna get all these stuff first before I...
Oh, hey, there's the...
The princess!
Wait, there's so many things here.
What?
Yeah, there's like...
I got my hot babe.
Yeah, but there's like more stuff though, that's the thing.
So I'm like, what's over there?
Okay, I want to look at the...
The side first.
So I open a gate here.
Oh, nice.
I did open this.
Oh, it was a film!
I missed out on the film.
Okay, I gotta go this way, and then...
Yeah, nice.
Give me my heart!
That's right!
That's right, baby!
Give me my heart!
Okay, and then...
Where does this do?
Okay, it's another film.
Oh my god, I don't want to jump off.
I feel like there might- I might die there.
Okay, we go down.
Yeah, I knew that was death.
I felt like that seemed like death right there.
All right, now Oswald has to see me.
I'm his long-lost brother that totally doesn't resent me or anything.
Oswald completed us in half the time, so I begrudgingly commend you.
The doors turned on as with our fearless leader are now open, but he will not be pleased.
He is the greatest hero you will ever meet.
Move on.
All right, time to meet my...
My hero.
All right.
Oh my god, he built himself his own little throne room and everything.
Hello, Oswald.
I'm your younger brother here.
His hair isn't selling.
I get that he resents me, but...
Oh gosh, you think?
I'm Oswald.
Before that, I used to be popular.
A star.
Until you stole my popularity, mouse.
My name is Mickey.
Believe me, I know.
Your name and likeness are on all this junk.
For years, I've looked at this mountain.
So, wondering why you all got the success I deserved.
For a long time, I tried to make the best of it.
Try to make a nice place for all the other forgotten children.
Especially my sweetie.
We're doing okay until the thinner disaster.
Come see, rabbit.
Let me clean this up.
The disaster unleashed the block.
I've been fighting.
Oh my god, he got...
They talk so fast.
Oh, nothing.
It's not...
I saw a screen in the house.
What happened to her?
Like you said, it's not important.
Why are you carrying away?
You always have what you need.
A heart?
Forgotten characters lose their heart.
No one can leave.
I used to have a heart.
Ah, so you kidnapped me!
Not me, the mad doctor.
I don't even want you here!
I wish you'd just get out!
In fact, you can still have your heart.
Jamar City has a Moonliner rocket.
We can fly it out of Wasteland.
Meet me in tomorrow.
But Oswald with a heart?
We can't leave.
What is this plan?
Oh my god, is this Kingdom Hearts?
Oh my god, they're like the Heartless!
Let's get back to the Mean Street to see what happened while we were away.
On the way, you can check with the folks here at Oswald for any news.
Oh my god, guys!
It's like they're the Heartless!
And I'm Sora!
I'm actually playing Kingdom Hearts!
I was playing Kingdom Hearts all along!
Oh yeah, here.
It's the prequel!
Thanks for connecting me to another region, Mickey!
Take this power spark as a reward!
All right.
You know what?
I think this is a good time to pause here.
Oh my god, this has been four hours.
I've been having fun though!
I've been enjoying Epic Mickey so far.
I like platformers, so...
It's been a long time since we played a 3D platformer.
So it's been a fun time, uh, enjoying it so far.
See you guys, I'm not...
He still likes me.
Wait, does he...
No consequences!
Consequences!
Tuki, murder history!
Tuki, stop!
Tuki, that's a one-stopper!
We can't...
Who told her?
Your last platform was Patrice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The murderer on the run.
Oh my god!
I can do anything!
I can drive by sitting out the town.
No, I can't stop it!
Moody!
Where's Moody?
Someone stop her.
Just like the real Mickey, she has become her true self.
Anyway, it's been fun so far.
I'm actually... in Lucia Morality.
I'm having a lot of fun playing Epic Mickey.
I think... I'm definitely gonna try and finish Epic Mickey in part 2 though, for sure.
In the part 2.
Because I'm halfway... Am I halfway, guys?
How far am I, in general?
Uh...
I knew... Guys, no!
I'm still getting the good end.
I just found out there's no consequences.
I...
About one third... Okay, I think we can...
I think we can finish it in part 2.
I'm pretty sure.
Is this game supposed to... Yeah, I mean, we're already...
Whoa, it's up... 12 hours?
Okay, maybe not in part 2.
Like, one, four, four, one, three.
Nah...
I don't know.
Do you guys think I can finish it in the second part?
If I do a long stream?
No, Scott.
See, maybe a part 3?
Okay, we'll...
I'm not sure you can get the gold stars.
No!
Okay, okay, we'll do it.
We'll finish it in part 3.
In part 2, we'll see how far we can get.
Let's see how far we can get in part 2.
And then part 3, we'll finish it in part 3.
Alright, let's do it.
Let's...
Let's save real quick.
I should... Can I save here?
Back to main menu?
I should be able to.
Yeah.
That was fun though.
I had a fun time.
Let's go to the chatting screen.
Uh...
Let's go here.
That was fun.
I had a lot of fun.
Playing it.
Um, I love Disney stuff so I'm glad.
Not the newer Disney stuff because...
New Disney has been, you know...
New Disney has fallen off a lot.
As we all know.
So...
Um...
But I do...
I like reminiscing about the old Disney stuff.
Um...
So...
It was...
It was really fun.
I had a lot of good...
A lot...
I had a really good time going...
Um...
Going through Disney things today.
Let me...
Let me grab the super chat.
Guys!
Let me grab it real quick!
Ba ba ba drum....
Ba ba ba drum...
Ba ba ba...
Hehehehehehe...
Uh...
Let's see.
Let me find it for us...
Ba ba ba da ma ba ba nam...
Ba ba ba diga dum...
It's been so long since I pulled.
Sorry, guys.
I'm just finding the superchats right now.
It's been a while since I've pulled up the superchat... actual superchat page for it.
Supers!
Alright, I got it.
I don't remember which one I've read and which one I haven't, though.
Because I've been all over the place.
Seijin, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know who made it, but they're a genius.
Thank you, thank you, Akasupa.
Oh yeah, by the way, guys.
Birthday merch is out.
So you guys having the birthday merch, this is your chance.
Birthday merch will end on August 4th for the pre-orders.
So make sure you grab them!
Wait, I did talk to... okay, so...
What I hate the most is FOMO.
So I did tell... I did ask...
Okay, I had a long argument with my manager about this.
But basically how the merch stuff is done.
Because I don't like FOMO.
Especially when the pre-orders are super short time.
Usually, like, you know, two to three weeks is when the pre-order is, like.
So I asked them if it was possible for the merch that's currently on the store.
And then, like, to...
When at the end, we're gonna order the items that's ordered currently.
And then we'll order a bulk amount.
Like, maybe, like, plus X amount later.
So we can still keep the items up on the store.
And for a bit longer.
Like, longer than a month.
Keep it longer than a month.
And then so, like, people who are still, you know, have finally...
Finally, you know, have enough money to buy.
I know, because, like, it's a lot of merch stuff, too, on the store.
And everything.
So...
It's not just the birthday merch.
But it's also for the other items that's on the store at the moment.
And I asked them if they could keep it so that you guys can still order it.
Like, in August and September.
Until, like, the items come in stock.
And then we can, like, change the pre-order stuff to, like, livestock.
So that, you know, like, being in...
Oh, it's on the store now.
So you can buy it.
If you want it to...
Like, you know, we have the items in the warehouse now.
So I did say...
But in that, we did say, like, if the bulk items that we ordered...
Are, like, already, like...
Are bought up by the end of, like...
By the time, like, the items get here.
Then, like, we'll see if there's interest.
And some...
Like, what are the lower interest items.
And what should, like, the higher interest items.
So, like, if there's, like, a lower interest items.
Maybe we'll do, like, one last pre-order or something.
And then, like, take it off the store after that.
Stuff like that.
So this is, like, the plans for the future of the items.
It's the merch and stuff.
Or the Doki merch.
Because I just want to give you guys more time to be able to...
I want to give you guys more time to be able to order some of these items.
Because, you know, we launched a lot of things at once, too.
So I know that, you know, you guys have to make sure to keep aware of your own finances and stuff like that.
So I wanted to give you guys more time.
If you guys really wanted something on the store but can't afford it yet and still, like, you know, need more time for it to afford it.
And so I was like, oh, can we keep it in the store longer?
Um, longer than, um, a month?
And they're like, yeah, we can... we're gonna... so they're planning on ordering some, like, the items in a little bit more, like, a bulk order of it.
So like... I don't know how many extra they're ordering, but they're ordering extra for it when, uh, the technical pre-order is done.
So like, those who pre-order will, you know, guarantee they get their items.
And then we'll have, like, extra stock for those who are ordering in August or September and stuff like that.
Uh, so we can still get the items in time, too.
But yeah, that's a little merch update.
Fudgetop, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you seen Walt Disney's animatronic?
It's kind of controversial because of the way it looks.
Can't believe they used that instead of his frozen body.
Oh yeah, the frozen body of Walt Disney that's under Disney World, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Did you see that video of that girl trying to do an impression of you?
Yeah, I saw that on my feed, on my Twitter feed, and there's... She said that my accent is like a valley girl accent.
I didn't even realize I sounded like a valley girl.
And she tried to do an impression of me.
I can't tell if it's accurate because her voice is a lot higher than mine.
So like when she was like doing an impression of mine, my accent, like the way I talk, it was a lot higher.
So I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell if it was accurate or not because like, I don't know.
Because her voice is higher.
So like if it was pitched like my voice, then like maybe I could tell the similarities.
But, um, but I couldn't tell.
I couldn't, I don't know.
Because like, I don't know if she's getting my intonations or whatever.
Yeah, so I don't know if it's close or not because I actually can't tell.
But her breakdown of it was interesting.
I found, like, to be fair, I skimmed through the video.
I didn't watch the entire thing.
I skimmed through it.
But her breakdown of it was pretty interesting when she was like doing an analysis of my voice.
Because obviously like, you know, I don't know.
I don't know how my voice is like.
Um, I also read, I don't know, I think you guys know this.
But like, what you hear yourself is different from what you actually sound like to other people.
So I don't actually know what I sound like to other people.
Because what I, because like, you, you don't know what you yourself sound like.
Um, all right.
Uh, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Frass, thank you for the super chat.
The worst part is, I'm gonna put my hoodie down.
Since it's like, casual now.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, my, the worst part is like, I don't remember which one I've read and which one I haven't.
Uh, next C, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your voice is very distinctive.
Always love to hear.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Um, I'm glad.
I'm glad.
I think my voice, like I said, it's like, very...
Either people love my voice or people hate my voice.
It's like, one or the other.
Because like, I'm more...
I think it's also because like, VTubers, I think like, the status quo when it comes to VTubing is that usually, like, the typical VTuber is, like, not loud in a more, like, cutesy voice or, like, more mellow, quiet, cutesy voice.
So, like, I'm, like, the more of a loud mouth and stuff like that, so it's, like, I'm loud and I laugh a lot.
So, like, it's either you love it or you hate it.
It's very polarizing, which I've learned, and to accept, because you can't satisfy everybody.
Mm-hmm.
Um...
Let's see.
I'm trying to... I'm just trying to figure out which one I've read and which one I haven't, guys.
I'm sorry.
I've lost track.
LC, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I guess that's one way to get your Groks up.
Oh, yeah, at Grok.
At my future wife, Grok.
Uh, Kyro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The birthday talk reminded me it's my birthday today.
I love it.
Happy birthday from my Kamiyoshi.
You, if it's not too much to ask, of course.
Happy birthday.
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Kyro.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Gia, thank you in the super chat, thank you, thank you.
That's why your songs, I believe, is hard to cover, too.
Because you have a unique tone that adds flavor to your song.
Thank you.
Thank you in the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Manny, thank you in the super chat.
Oh my god, we are like pandas.
Bria, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And this is how the world ends.
Not with a bang, but with a bragoon.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did somebody say that door to darkness?
Um, Parappa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your voice is always so cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now you're gonna realize... I haven't used my, like... I haven't done my child voice in so long.
Um...
I realized that, cause I was like, oh yeah, cause there's never, like, a time to use it, you know?
Some people, like, some people don't realize that I can be a ve- like, I- I can voice act as, like, a child.
Um, wait, uh, or my old man voice, yeah.
Wait, um, um, wait, let me see if I- let's see if...
Pop, wait.
Pop, what's me?
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tumblr girls first got ya.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Fuzz, thank you for the super chat.
One day I'll catch your full stream.
Happy birthday and wish you and everyone here well.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, that's weird.
That's- that's- Look, that child has gone through a lot.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't remember how to do the old man.
Hello.
Mike.
I just think of, like, the giant, like, Mega Evolution Pikachu.
Is it Mega Evolution Pikachu?
Where, where... No, Gigantamax.
I think of a Gigantamax Pikachu.
And, you know, like, he's like, Pika.
Pika.
Gigantamax Doki.
Mike.
Cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pika.
Gak.
Curse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're gonna have to play another FNAF game after Kingdom Hearts playthrough.
Uh, Gus, thank- Yeah.
I do if I want to fix the algorithm on my channels.
I don't know, I feel like...
That's what I'm saying.
I think Kingdom Hearts 1 was very nostalgia-filled for it, because, like, I think if I try to play Kingdom Hearts 1 again, I'm gonna go fucking crazy with the controllers and the boss fights.
Like, I'm not playing on Proud mode.
Like, that- that shit is...
That's just torture.
Like, I feel like Kingdom Hearts 1 just had so much fucking bullshit, um, that I was thrown.
That- I- I remember that I didn't know what the fuck to do, that I actually bought the- the guidebook, because, like, uh, Because you remember, like, back then, there were, like, little, like, tutorial guidebooks before, like, people googled the- like,
walkthroughs and stuff?
You get, like, the strategy guide, and I actually had the Kingdom Hearts 1 strategy guide, because I didn't know what the fuck to do, because, like, um, um, Kingdom Hearts 1 was, like, not self-explan- like, like, you need yellow paint.
Like, you- You- you actually need yellow paint for the first game.
Like, yeah, because I- I was, like, I was so confused on where to go, and, like, how to set up, like- like, like, start the cutscenes and stuff.
Um, I like Kingdom Hearts 2.
I replayed Kingdom- I remember, like, growing up, I replayed Kingdom Hearts 2, like, I think, like, three times, I'm pretty sure.
Uh, I enjoyed Kingdom Hearts 2.
I replayed Kingdom Hearts 1, like, once, and that was because I never- I didn't finish it the first time around, so I was, like, this time I will finish it this- now.
And then I never completed Kingdom Hearts 3, because that game sucked.
I told you guys, I got to the Frozen level, and I was, like, that's enough.
That's a- That's enough Kingdom Hearts for me.
I'm so sad.
I wish Kingdom Hearts 3 was a lot better.
I wish it was, because we waited so long, you know?
We- we waited so fucking long for the sequel.
Yeah, I've seen enough, yeah.
I didn't even finish the Frozen level, too.
I stopped halfway.
We were cl- I was climbing the mountain- like, I was like, we- me and Sora.
I was- I was climbing a mountain in the- the Frozen or whatever, and then, like, I just stopped.
Like, I just turned off my console.
Like, I- I turned off my- I- I- was it PlayStation 3 or 4?
I don't remember if it was on PlayStation 3 or 4.
I just turned it off, and I was like, that's enough.
I- I- I never came back to it.
Um, Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, finding a game-list?
That's a problem for future Doki.
I'm so glad I'm not her.
Uh, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you- thank you.
Very sadly, pretend it doesn't exist.
Because not only is it gacha, it's a shitty cash grab gacha.
I'm so sad that the Madoka game was- is a gacha game.
I was actually willing to- I was actually willing to play a JRPG because it's Madoka.
I told you guys, I was fucking crazy obsessed with Madoka.
I even have, like, um, like, I- when I- when the movie, the, uh, the Rebellion movie came out, um, it was playing on select theaters, and I went to a movie theater and brought in a plushie of Q-bay, uh, Q-B to, like, like, um, poking out of my- my bag and everything,
and, like, have Q-Bs, like, sitting next to me while watching the movie.
Um, and I was so- I- like, I was- I had, like, I didn't even have, like, a life-size replica of- figure of Q-B and everything, too.
Like, I was so obsessed over Madoka, and I was- literally, I would have played a JRPG on my channel if it was an actual RPG.
If I- if it was an actual game game and not just a gacha game, especially if it's, like, a gacha game that's, like, that, like, locks important story elements behind it, too.
I'm so sad.
Um, let's see.
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b So if you die to a boss, you have to watch the cutscene every time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank God you can skip cutscenes now.
Hello!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I played every Kingdom Hearts game and also a big fan of the series too.
And I only understand that the big key is a key.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
I was half expecting Doki's Birth by Sleep video to be a Just a Pancake video.
I don't even remember which one I linked.
I don't remember who it was.
It's like, this is a JRPG game.
What role am I playing?
The fucking victim?
I love... there's like so many videos that just live rent free in my head.
And that's like one of... that's like... I have...
Right now, I have four videos that live rent free in my head that I'll always think about.
The first one would be... the first one would be like...
John Manon.
John... I don't know why, but always think about that video.
The other one is that one.
What role am I playing?
The fucking victim?
The third one would be Fat Yoshi's Song.
The... the... okay, wait.
For those who've never heard of the Fat Yoshi's Song...
The big... sorry, Big Yoshi's Song.
Yeah!
He's just... big bone.
Um...
But that video also...
The big Yoshi's Down.
That's like one of my favorite songs ever.
Um...
That lives rent free in my head as well.
And then...
The fourth one...
Oh my...
I'm starting...
I must have liked the video.
Um...
Let's see if I can find it.
I know I liked the video.
Because I was like...
One day I'll show this video.
Uh...
Where is it?
Is it...
Did I like it on Twitter?
Or did I...
Yeah, because if I'm going to show...
If I'm going to talk about this video...
I want to see if I like...
If I bookmarked it.
Okay, maybe it's three videos.
Because I don't...
I don't actually remember the fourth.
I...
I don't really remember...
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
Um...
Okay.
I was looking through my Twitter bookmarks.
Because I was like...
Um...
Things I need to show...
My chat.
Dumb...
Like...
Dumb shit...
That pops up on my...
Um...
On my Twitter feed.
That I have to show chat.
But...
And I found...
And I saw...
Like it was bookmarked on my Twitter.
Because I was like...
Remember to show this.
It's really stupid.
But...
Uh...
Let's go watch the Minecraft movie.
Like real men.
I'm going with my girlfriend.
Um...
Did your girlfriend pay for the server we used to play on?
Did your girlfriend pick up your items when you died?
Did your girlfriend build the automatic iron farm?
Don't ever speak to me again.
Me...
How dare you?
You're not a real homie.
I'm your girlfriend, bro.
Dang...
Man just lost a homie.
I love that screenshot.
It's so fucking good.
Um...
Oh my god.
There's so many things I like saved on my bookmarks.
I forgot to tell you guys about.
Um...
I want to do this one day.
I want to do this.
Where like...
If we ever get a Dragoon plushie...
Like an official one made.
I want to do this.
Where...
Basically...
This video is basically where...
If he doesn't get a gacha...
Or like the thing he wants...
He starts to cut...
Every piece of Luigi.
Like slowly cut...
Piece by piece...
Of Luigi.
And he doesn't get his pull.
And I want to do...
And I get...
The official Dragoon plushie.
And I'll be like...
Today I'm going to open this.
Why?
Wait a second.
There has to be a punishment.
I...
One day.
If I ever get...
We ever...
Whenever...
Okay, not if.
We get an official Dragoon plushie.
Something's wrong with you.
The only time you...
Now you guys can't...
I love how he like starts taping him up.
It's actually crazy.
It's...
Um...
And they're like...
Here's Dragoon 3.0.
That's messed up.
I think it's a great idea.
I...
No...
Why?
Because I know you guys are gonna wish bad luck to me.
And I'm teaching you all a lesson.
You have to give me your gotcha luck.
Let's see.
Uh...
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh,
buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh,
bu Like, the Epic Mickey concept art was actually so fucked up.
Like... Like, it was crazy.
Um... Okay, this is like... Okay, I'm gonna tell you right now, disclaimer, it's like, really...
HAHAHAHA!
It's crazy!
It's basically like... Okay, guys, remember like, the fucked up concept stuff from- concept art from Pokemon?
It's basically like that.
But like, this were like... This was like the rejected concept art.
For Epic Mickey.
When it comes to the enemies.
Like, some of the enemies that you can encounter in- in Epic Mickey.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
HAHAHAHA!
This is a children's game!
Like, excuse me?
Um... And there's more.
There's more, by the way.
This was... There's more.
They made... There is a... There- Oh my god.
Look at this one.
Look at... Look at this.
The centipede.
Oh my god.
That... We were robbed!
I... I can't... Guys, I think I can see why these are cut.
Alright.
HAHAHAHA!
Bro, it reminds me of the... Of Alice in Wonderland game.
The madness... Uh... American McGee's Alice in Wonderland.
That's what it reminds me of.
The Mickey Centipede with Abraham Lincoln as the... HAHAHAHA!
The fact that Abraham Lincoln is on the head of the fucking centipede.
Like, what... What is this?
Get that ogget out of my screen.
Why?
Because it's like the pre- like the president's room or some shit.
Like, I... HAHAHAHA!
Jesus Christ.
But yeah, no, like, the... The con... The concept of art for Epic Mickey...
I think they... I'm pretty sure they wanted to do, like, an actual, like, horror game.
Uh... Like, an actual horror, horror game of Epic Mickey before they pivoted or something.
Because, like... I... Why was that a thing?
Why... Why did they do this?
Paper Ham Lincoln did not die for this.
HAHAHAHA!
I didn't... HAHAHAHA!
Uh... Was there anything... Anymore?
I literally googled, like, Epic Mickey concept art and, like, some of the shit is insane, actually.
Uh... I played American McGee's Alice before.
I have.
Um... And the sequels.
Did I play the sequel as well?
I did, right?
I did.
I remember.
Yeah.
Did I?
Yeah, no, I did.
I did.
I played the original and I played the sequel to it.
Um... It's been a long time.
I actually really liked American McGee's Alice and the sequel.
Um... It was, uh... It's one of my favorite series.
Uh... GGG, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not getting sleep now.
Yeah, it's actually... It's one of my favorite games.
I really liked the lore behind it.
Let's see...
Uh...
Uh... Gamer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I played this when it first came out on Wii and was happy when it got remastered.
I'd say my only complaint is some things don't carry over in your game plus.
Excellent game otherwise.
Hope you enjoy it.
I did.
I can't wait to finish it.
Um...
I'm wondering... No, I was gonna say do I do two parts next week?
But I wanna...
Try and get as much Elden Ring done as possible.
Uh... Because I know that that game is gonna take me fucking forever.
Ha ha!
Ha!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, uh...
Pup pup pup pup pup pup.
Let's see.
Uh...
All right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh... Mickey Mouse is surprisingly talented for a...
Rodent.
Uh... Fudge Top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Simple minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Remember last time, Doki?
Beer o'clock.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It never ceased to amuse me that Epic Mickey is the brainchild of Warren Spector, the lead develop on Destiny X, Thief, and System Shock.
Oh, that makes a lot of sense how we got fucked up Mickey in those concept art then.
That actually makes a lot of sense now.
Um, if you think about it, because... Yeah.
Uh...
With the stuff he's done?
Oh, yeah.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, I already read that.
Thank you for the super chat, though.
Thank you.
Chris, thank you for the super chat.
Never forget that Kingdom Hearts King Mickey banished Pete to a different dimension.
Pete should have just said, oopsie-doopsie.
You should have wrote in his, like, little book and be like, I'm sorry.
I did a really bad thing, but I didn't mean it.
I love that little lore from, um, Kingdom Hearts 1 that Disney originally didn't want Mickey to be in Kingdom Hearts at all.
Because they're like, we don't want you to taint the mark, Mickey Mouse.
And then they just, like, they're like, but that's why he's, like, he's only there as, like, the shadow form of himself.
Because they're like, this is the only time we'll ever let you use Mickey Mouse in Kingdom Hearts.
Because they didn't know if the game was going to be good or not.
So they were scared.
They're like, oh, what if, what if it, they're like, oh, what if something, like, you know, what if the game tanks or stuff?
Um, so that's why you only see, like, he comes in at the last moment.
Where he just be like, uh-huh.
Oh, hey, everyone.
Don't worry, Riku.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna save you, Riku.
Don't worry, little anime boy.
Yeah, we'll let Goofy and Donald take the fall.
Um, King, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The last good Disney game was Mickey Mousecapades on an NES in 1987.
Mickey Mousecapades, I never played that.
To be fair, it's on an NES.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I...
Okay, no, I have played this.
And the reason why I played this...
Okay, those can relate.
Okay.
The people, you got, the ones that can relate to this are those with Asian parents slash grandparents.
And you have a handheld console, like, you know, like a Game Boy or Game Boy Advance.
Or, like, and then your grandparents or your parents would be like, Hey, look, I bought you a new game.
And look, it has a hundred games in one cartridge.
And you're like, what?
A hundred games?
So, how is that possible?
And back when you're younger, you didn't realize that bootlegs existed back then.
And you're like, wow, Mom.
Wow, Grandma.
That's so cool.
A hundred games?
Oh, boy.
Or in the...
Oh, really?
Like, like, Latin Households, too.
And...
So...
It was magic, you know?
You're like, wow!
And I remember the Mickey Mousecapades.
Because that was one of those games that was on, I think, the Game Boy.
With the 101 game.
Yeah, the good old memories.
Yeah.
But I didn't know that it was, like, bootleg.
Okay, so...
That was actually my first encounter.
With...
Like, um...
That was my first time experiencing Pokemon.
Um...
Because I would say my first time playing a Pokemon game was Pokemon Crystal.
But the thing is...
That was my first time experiencing a non-bootleg Pokemon game.
Because...
My grandma would buy me, like...
A bootleg version of Pokemon games.
And so, like...
Um...
So, like...
But there will be, like, in those, like, you know, 101 games.
So, there will be, like, Pokemon Yellow and Red.
And...
But then, like...
The thing about those games...
Is that...
You can't save.
That's the thing.
You can't actually save...
In those games.
So, like, every time I would be, like...
Oh, let me try out this...
Let me try Pokemon Yellow.
It would go back from the beginning.
So, I never was able to, like...
And then it would be in, like, Chinese or Japanese.
So, I didn't really know how to play the game, either.
Because it'd be...
It'd be in a different language.
And I thought...
I just...
I kept thinking, like...
Oh, maybe I just clicked...
I just didn't know...
I didn't know how to read it.
So, I don't know how to save.
But...
In the end, it just...
Those games just can't save.
Because they're not legit.
But...
My first real game...
Playing the real version...
Was Pokemon Crystal.
When I finally got a real edition of the game.
Uh...
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Legit console is so good...
That it cost a short circuit...
That made the whole neighborhood have no power.
People full of Latin American shenanigans.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
But yeah.
I got the Pokemon Yellow.
And I never...
I could never progress...
Past, like...
The first town.
Because I could never save the game.
And...
Yeah.
If you had...
You couldn't save in the bootleg versions.
Like the one that has, like...
101.
Sonic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
If you're thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
Bottom, bottom, bottom.
Um...
I...
The Iris...
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That game looks fun.
I wonder why Disney stopped making...
Games.
It's just not profitable.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean...
If...
For Disney...
They do make games.
But it's just like...
What's the word?
Uh...
Microtransactions.
They don't make actual games.
Games anymore.
They just want to do games where you have to do microtransactions.
Yeah.
Microtransaction and gacha games.
They don't make like actual games anymore.
Because to them, it's just not profitable.
With the amount of like years they have to put into it.
And they're here for like fast profit.
Not like long-term profit.
Like not fast profit.
Not here to make like actual like...
You know...
A good art form or something.
Yeah.
Like there's so many like...
Phone games that Disney makes.
That always plays on like YouTube ads.
Or like...
Um...
Like YouTube ads.
Or ads.
And...
What else?
I don't know.
But I always see ads for like the one with the...
The puzzle ones.
I don't remember what it's called.
Um...
There was like a puzzle...
There was a puzzle game that keeps popping up on my ad feed.
Uh...
Scrum.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Like how Konami started making pachinko.
Because pachinko just is just more profitable.
Uh...
Hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Santino.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good job.
You did it.
Yay.
Let's see.
Oh, that was my last super chat.
I did it!
I did all my super chat reading!
Oh my god!
I'm so good at super chat reading now.
It's so nice to, like, you know, do an after stream, chatting stream again, and just, you know, hang out with you guys.
I finally have time to do stuff like that.
Hippie!
Um, but yeah, it sucks, though, that Disney doesn't do, like, actual games anymore.
Mostly just remasters to, like, you know, they're, like... I feel like remasters, they do.
Because they can just outsource it to a different company to do an app for them.
And usually, usually, you know, they have a passion for it.
Because, like, you know, the developers might, like... Oh, Captain!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You know, developers that may remake the game or something, the remaster for it, maybe, like, it's, like, a passion for them, too.
And they're, like, oh, I grew up with this and I wanna... Um, I grew up with this game and, like, you know, um, I wanna remake it.
And it's from Disney.
But I mean, like, what's it called?
What is that called?
It's like how, you know, how, like, Marvel outsourced their game to NetEase.
And like, what was that company?
Which that company is making that Marvel, the Marvel fighting game too.
They outsource it to like these companies to make their games for them.
And then DC, all DC has is that stupid, like, the mobile ad story.
What was it?
The one where they have to build, like, a base or whatever.
Like, all DC has is that stupid, like, game where they're trying to build a base or whatever underneath the ground because of, like, some zombie apocalypse.
Oh my god.
Before I bought YouTube, before I bought, like, the YouTube premium shit, I would always get that fucking ad.
Yeah.
Never been the same after Arkham Knight, no.
And they, like, fucking, um, they sold out to made a VR, like, a VR game too.
I swear to God, I think, I think VR games are, like, was, like, a trend.
Like, I don't understand.
I feel like no one really plays VR games other than for VR chat in general or just to hang out with people.
Like, I feel like VR is just more better as a social hangout thing rather than, yeah, rather than, like, actual gaming gaming.
Um, so, it feels like, who is it for?
Like, um...
Um, some of them were good.
I think it was, like, like, years ago it was good.
Like, the OG games, like, were good, but I feel like social-wise, uh, there are...
It's, like, I feel like VR is more for, like, so...
Other than Beat Saber, I know people fucking love Beat Saber.
Uh, there is, like, a huge barrier, though, for VR and stuff, which I get.
But, uh, I heard Minecraft VR is, like, very disorienting in general, uh, for people.
Um, Beat Saber is fun, I would admit, though.
Beat Saber is really fun.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I need to walk Dad tonight because, um, he needs his walkies.
Um, but I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me today.
Um, tomorrow is Elden Ring.
I was thinking about, like, uh, I'll see if my CPU is okay.
Well, because I actually bought a CPU upgrade, but, um, the only issue is that I don't know how to install a CPU, so I have to take it to a store to have them install my CPU for me.
But also, my PC is very, very heavy.
So, um, so, so, like, um, the reason why, like, the...
I'm gonna see if Elden Ring still, like, stutters, but if it still stutters...
Because every time I did Elden Ring, um...
Because sometimes it stutters and sometimes it doesn't.
I thought I fixed it, but the last time we played Elden Ring, it still stuttered a little bit.
So, like, I don't know why.
Like, but then, like, when I...
The two, two, two playthroughs ago, it didn't stutter, but then it stuttered again.
So, like, I don't know.
But every time...
But every time it stutters, it just goes to a hundred.
Um, um, it goes to a hundred and stuff for a CPU.
So, if it stutters again, maybe I'll...
Maybe I'll put my upgrade in.
I bought the upgrade a while ago.
Um, I bought the upgrade, like, a month and a half ago.
But then I never did anything with it because it's just...
The PC is so heavy, guys.
And I have to, like, carry the PC down and get the Uber and then, like...
And then, like, carry the PC over.
Actually, no, I could ask the Uber guy to carry my PC.
But it's still a lot to just get it out of my room.
Just to get it out of my room in general.
But anyway, I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated, posture check, get up and around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you still for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.